et nous allons pouvoir commencer
cette audition chers collègues chers
invités chers internautes qui nous
suivait en ligne je vous souhaite à tous
la bienvenue pour la première audition
publique que nous organisons depuis le
renouvellement de l'Office fin juillet à
la suite des élections législatives
avant d'engager cette audition l'Office
doit procéder à quelques nominations de
rapporteurs à la suite de la réunion du
bureau qui a eu lieu jeudi dernier pour
la note scientifique sur les effets de
la pollution lumineuse sur la
biodiversité j'ai reçu la candidature
d'Annick Jacquemet sénatrice
pour l'audition publique sur les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
sur la biodiversité j'ai reçu la
candidature de Florence lasarade
sénatrice pour l'étude sur la sobriété
énergétique le bureau avait identifié
comme rapporteur Olga hivernais député
et Stéphane piennois sénateur il avait
laissé ouverte la possibilité de
désigner deux autres corps rapporteurs
je n'ai cependant pas été saisi de
candidature nouvelle je vous propose
donc d'approuver les nominations
d'Annick Jacquemet Florence la Sarrade
Olga giverner Stéphane piennoir aux
travaux que je viens de citer s'il n'y a
pas d'opposition ou d'abstention il en
est ainsi décidé très bien
j'en viens donc à l'audition publique de
ce jour comme vous le savez l'Office
procède à des études pour répondre aux
saisines des bureaux et des commissions
de chacune des deux assemblées il
établit des notes scientifiques au
format plus courts que ces rapports
d'études et organise des auditions
publiques en réunissant sur un sujet
d'actualité des experts d'horizons
variés c'est ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui sur le thème de
l'alimentation
ultra transformée cette audition
s'inscrit dans le cadre du travail comme
un actuellement la sénatrice en gel
previl pour établir une note
scientifique sur les impacts de
l'alimentation
ultra transformée l'Office a déjà
travaillé sur des thèmes voisins je
pense en particulier aux notes
scientifiques que nous avons publié sur
les enjeux sanitaires et
environnementaux de l'huile de palme sur
environnementaux de la viande rouge ou
encore dernièrement sur le microbiote
intestinal
je précise que l'audition
de ce matin est diffusé en direct sur le
site internet et les comptes Facebook et
Twitter du Sénat elle sera ensuite
disponible en vidéo à la demande sur les
sites de nos deux assemblées
par ailleurs comme nous en avons pris
l'habitude à l'office les internautes
ont la possibilité de soumettre des
questions en ligne par l'intermédiaire
de la plateforme dont le lien figure sur
les pages Internet de l'Office certaines
questions pourront ainsi être posées aux
participants lors de cette audition
et vous voyez le timing est toujours
impeccable le premier vice-président de
l'Office sénateur Gérard Longuet
souhaite-il ajouter quelques mots
d'introduction sur cette audition
publique de l'alimentation
ultra transformé
non
enfin bon c'est pas une tragédie allez
on attaque
bien écoutez je laisse à présent la
parole à la sénatrice en gel previl pour
introduire nos débats qui se dérouleront
sous la forme de deux tables rondes
merci monsieur le Président
invité chers internautes l'alimentation
et l'un des déterminants majeurs de la
survenue de maladies chroniques dont le
coût humain bien sûr en premier social
et économique est devenu considérable
aussi pour prévenir ces maladies la
promotion d'un régime alimentaire sain
est un véritable apéritif de santé
publique en matière de nutrition
l'approche classique considère les
aliments au regard de leur composition
en nutriments mais le développement de
l'alimentation industrielle a vu émerger
une nouvelle vision basée sur le degré
de transformation subie par les aliments
les plus transformés d'entre eux dit
ultra transformés et en cela une
définition communément admise parlent
des aliments ayant subi une
transformation importante c'est à dire
utilisant des substances dérivées
d'aliments lactose caséine huile
l'hydrogénée etc et des additifs
restaurant arômes exauceur de goût agent
de texture et donc ces aliments ultra
transformés pouvant être associés à
d'importantes conséquences sanitaires
cette nouvelle classification figure par
exemple dans le récent rapport
d'information sur la lutte contre le
visiter qui a fait au nom fait au nom de
la commission des affaires sociales au
Sénat et rapporteur il propose de faire
évoluer l'algorithme et l'affichage du
nutriscor pour mieux prendre en compte
les aliments ultra transformés
d'envisager l'instauration d'une taxe
sur les aliments ultra transformés à
travers l'audition de ce jour l'Office
souhaite questionner cette nouvelle
approche d'un point de vue scientifique
bien sûr dans un premier temps ce sera
l'objet de la première table ronde nous
allons explorer les impacts de la
consommation d'aliments ultra
transformés et réfléchir à la place qui
doit être donné à cette approche dans
les recommandations de politiques
nutritionnelles dans un second temps
nous nous intéresserons aux conséquences
du développement l'alimentation
industrielle sur les habitudes et les
comportements alimentaires la première
table ronde est donc consacrée aux
impacts de l'alimentation ultra
transformée sur la santé humaine et à la
place qui doit être donnée à cette
approche dans les recommandations nous
avons le plaisir d'accueillir comme
intervenant monsieur Anthony farde
chargé de recherche à l'inrae dans
lui-même unité nutrition humaine madame
mathildeouvier directrice de recherche à
l'INSERM et directrice de l'équipe de
recherche en épidémiologie
nutritionnelle et Monsieur Bernard sourd
poste doctorant dans cette même équipe
et enfin Madame Véronique Brasco
directrice de VAB nutrition et membres
correspondant de l'Académie
d'Agriculture de France monsieur fardey
je vous laisse la parole pour votre
propos liminaire d'environ une dizaine
de minutes merci
on voit votre
notre projection oui donc merci pour
votre invitation et puis merci aussi
surtout d'avoir accepté que je puisse
intervenir en visio merci beaucoup donc
à votre demande je vais vous présenter
une approche holistique de l'ultra
transformation
donc mais je voulais déclarer quand même
lien d'intérêt parce que je suis membre
de diversités scientifiques ils m'ont
sollicité pour mes travaux notamment
pour mon approche holistique ça n'est
durable et qui ont intégré même certains
de mes travaux donc j'ai trois types de
comités scientifiques privées publiques
associatifs pour le privé évidemment je
vais citer siga donc qui est intégré
certains de mes travaux et
complexe suscare notamment
et au niveau public je citerai le centre
européenas sur la durabilité et le
programme alimentaire territorial du
Grand clairement livre à loi Forrez
on m'avait demandé de rappeler la
définition d'un élément ultra transformé
vous l'avez donné donc je vais essayer
de bref et constitue donc ça provient de
la classification brésilienne Nova le
concept a émergent en 2009
c'est un concept qui est plutôt en phase
avec la définition d'un aliment sain
pour la santé globale c'est-à-dire le
moins transformé possible mais aussi
l'attente des consommateurs qui
recherchent de plus en plus des aliments
moins transformés et naturels
la définition en fait est assez simple
c'est un aliment qui contient moins un
marqueur ultra transformation et donc la
finalité est avant tout de modifier ce
qu'on appelle les propriétés
sensorielles c'est à dire vous couleur
aromatique
on distingue quatre marqueurs les
additifs cosmétiques que vous avez cités
qui sont un peu moins de 40% des mutes
donc il y en a quand même plus de 60%
qui ne sont pas des additifs donc ultra
transformation ne se résume pas aux
additifs donc c'est avant tout les
textures en modificateurs de goût et
colorants les conservateurs en théorie
n'entre pas dans la définition d'ultra
transformation les arômes pour modifier
plutôt
l'aspect sensoriel au niveau du nez et
ce qu'on appelle les nutriments ultra
transformés lucides lipides protéines et
fibres
de protéines protéines hydrolysées
graisses hydrogénée sucre inverti sirop
de glucose amidon etc et enfin des
procédés technologiques très dénaturants
qui peuvent aussi modifier beaucoup
l'aliment qui sont plutôt récents et
modernes dans les axes en tarifs 70 80
comme les plus connus c'est le soufflage
et la cuisson extrusion qu'on va
retrouver dans les galettes de riz
soufflé ou les cernes petit déjeuner
pour enfants alors le point commun de
tous ces marqueurs et c'est ce qui se
rapproche moins des travaux avec une
approche holistique c'est qui ils sont
tous associés soit à une matrice très
dégradée ou artificialisée additif arôme
et nutriments ultra transformés sont
principalement issus du crating
alimentaire symbolisé ici à gauche ou on
craque des aliments un peu à l'image du
pétrole et on va en isoler les briques
élémentaires c'est à dire qu'on va
beaucoup plus loin que les procédés
classiques permettent mécaniques et
fermentaires d'où le mot ultra parce que
on va beaucoup plus loin en isolant les
briques alimentaires qui peuvent être
combinés dans de nouveaux aliments de
nouvelles matrices ou ajouter à des
vrais aliments pour en modifier les
aspects sensoriels donc on passe pour ça
qu'on parle aussi d'agent cosmétiques
donc le point commun c'est qu'on a soit
des composés absolument sommatrices qui
ont été extraits de leur matrice ou des
matrices dégradées artificialisme
je tiens à rappeler
c'est un concept empirique et holistique
c'est-à-dire qui est la classification
Nova pour nos auditeurs je pense il est
bon de la rappeler très brièvement donc
là j'insiste encore c'est une approche
empirique c'est-à-dire on part du réel
et on élabore de nouvelles théories par
induction et qu'on appelle les théories
unificatrices ou holistique donc c'est
ce qui caractérise moins ma démarche en
tant que chercheur aussi donc dans les
cuisines ils ont observé qu'il y avait
quatre groupes d'aliments les aliments
peu ou pas transformer mono-ingrédients
comme les fruits frais par exemple on va
retrouver le lait les yaourts etc et
dans le groupe de les ingrédients
culinaires qu'on utilise depuis très
longtemps comme le sucre les épices le
sel le poivre les huiles etc et quand on
ajoute des ingrédients culinaires au
groupe pain on a les aliments
transformés
et donc quand on ajoute les ingrédients
pulinaires regroupés on a les aliments
transformés
dont le but est d'augmenter la
conservation à petite échelle et la
palatabilité c'est-à-dire les propriétés
sensorielles donc on va retrouver les
plats à la maison le fromage le pain
traditionnels des plats des terroirs et
à peu près 30% des aliments industriels
donc on peut aussi acheter des aliments
industriels de qualité et enfin le
groupe 4 qui ressemble au groupe 3 mais
avec des ingrédients beaucoup plus
longues et ils ont appelé donc ces
ingrédients supplémentaires qu'on ne
retrouve normalement pas en cuisine et
qui sont d'origine strictement
industriel des agents pardon des
ingrédients additifs purifiques
cosmétiques pour augmenter améliorer les
propriétés sensorielles et avoir des
durées de conservation très longue à
grande échelle et ces aliments du groupe
la tendent à se substituer aux aliments
du groupe 3 voire à les imiter si le
pain de mie et laissera le
petit-déjeuner pour enfants remplacent
le vrai pain le soda en Amérique du Sud
remplace l'eau et les arômes peuvent
remplacer les vrais fruits
donc on a un danger ici qui est de
détourner les gens des aliments du
groupe 3 avec des aliments qui les
imitent
ce travail on l'a publié en début
d'année donc
pour moi l'aliment ultra transformé
d'abord un concept holistique
c'est-à-dire global basé sur la preuve
de concept que la matrice alimentaire
c'est-à-dire la structure de l'aliment
et le vecteur des nutriments et donc
gouverne les effets santé des nutriments
donc je distingue les causes la cause et
les effets je pense c'est important de
faire cette distinction à droite vous
avez la cause qui sont des matrices
alimentaires dégradées et artificialisé
donc ça c'est la cause que j'appelle la
proche holistique en préventif et vous
avez les effets effectivement
secondaires qui s'étudie plus selon une
approche réductionniste c'est-à-dire on
se focalise en sur des parties de
l'ensemble
sinon consomme beaucoup de ces aliments
ultra transformer qu'on observe la
littérature et bien ils peuvent
entraîner une consommation d'excès de
calories plus 20% qui sont
principalement des sucres et graisses
ajoutées dû à moins de mastication et de
satiété et une consommation de calories
par minute plus importante de l'excès de
sel pour les féculents index glycémique
plus élevé
des études montrent qu'ils sont en
général plus pauvres en micronutriments
protecteurs ils peuvent contenir de
nombreux xénobiotiques c'est-à-dire des
composés étrangers au corps humain que
notre corps n'avait pas l'habitude de
consommer seulement enfin que l'on
consomme maintenant en masse depuis
seulement 40 ans 45 ans ça peut être
plein de choses ça peut être des résidus
de pesticides les additifs de synthèse
des amis non modifiés des graisses
hydrogénées qui n'existent pas dans la
nature on peut avoir une perte de
synergie des composés bioactifs un
potentiel effet cocktail des additifs
qui n'a pas été beaucoup étudié donc qui
est plutôt à l'ordre de l'hypothèse et
puis la présence de perturbateurs
endocriniens potentiels donc si vous
voulez à gauche ici
on pourrait dire qu'on a le cocktail
idéal pour faire le lit des premières
dérégulations métaboliques qui peuvent
être surpo-obésité diabète de type 2 et
foie gras humains c'est à cause
hépatique entraînant ensuite des
maladies chroniques plus graves
alors la question que je pose c'est je
distingue bien les effets de la cause
donc au niveau des effets donc on est
plus dans une approche de décortiquer
des mécanismes une approche qui est
utile mais qui est sur le plus long
terme mais je pose une première question
et je reviendrai en conclusion attend le
temps de décortiquer tous les mécanismes
selon cette approche réductionniste car
vous voyez qu'il peut y avoir des
millions de combinaisons entre tous les
additifs tous les arômes tous les
objectifs
et je pense qu'il faut plutôt d'abord
agir sur la cause car il suffit
seulement de réduire la cause
c'est-à-dire l'aliment ultra transformé
et forcément par effet on réduit tout ce
qu'il y a à droite car pour moi si vous
voulez et c'est donc mon approche
holistique c'est l'ensemble qui pose
problème c'est l'ensemble et non une
partie une seule partie de l'ensemble
avant dernière diapo donc toujours
l'approche holistique de l'ultra
transformation ce que je veux essayer de
vous montrer dans cette diapo c'est que
les aliments ultra transformés c'est pas
seulement la santé ce n'est que la
partie émergée de l'iceberg et je
voudrais je voulais m'intéresser à la
partie mergée c'est à dire tout le
système socio-économique qui sous-tend
une fin transformation et je pense que
c'est aussi ça qu'il faut questionner
donc il y a une dimension il y a une
multidimensionnalité au concept
d'aliments ultra transformés pour faire
simple nous avons voulu de manière
toujours empirique
voir comment était lié une consommation
globalisée massive des aliments ultra
transformés et les différentes sécurités
alimentaires donc il y a la sécurité
alimentaire et sanitaire nutritionnelle
santé socio-économique et
environnementale
transformés remplissent très bien de
sécurité ce que j'appelle la sécurité
alimentaire c'est à dire des calories
plutôt bon marché et accessibles au plus
grand nombre dans les grandes villes sur
toute la planète et sanitaires c'est des
aliments très très sûr d'un point de vue
toxicologique ils peuvent se conserver
très longtemps ça leur permet de
parcourir aussi les milliers de
kilomètres etc mais ça a été fait au
détriment de trois autres sécurité
environnementales nutritionnel santé et
socio-économique je m'explique
si l'on revient la définition de l'ultra
transformée donc il faut qu'il y ait au
moins un marqueur d'ultra transformation
donc nous nous sommes demandés d'où
venaient ces marqueurs et bien on
s'aperçoit assez rapidement que la
majorité de ces marqueurs proviennent
d'élevage très intensifs maltraite
associés à de la maltraitance animale et
de monoculture très intensive une
agriculture très intensive avec très peu
de biodiversité puisque très peu
d'aliments finalement sont craqués et
fractionnés sur la planète pour produire
ces marqueurs
ce qui est associé à une pollution
plastique avec le siramballage qui a
très bien documenté notamment pour les
sodas dans le monde l'utilisation
massive d'engrais de pesticides
d'herbicides de la déforestation
notamment pour produire du soja qui va
nourrir des animaux en fidelotte en
Amérique du Nord très intensifs qui vont
donner des produits animaux ultra
transformés et une menace de
l'agriculture paysanne car évidemment
ces grandes monocultures intensives et
bien font disparaître les petits paysans
qui peuvent alimenter les bidons vides
donc ce n'est pas mon sujet ce sera le
l'exposé suivant mais ces aliments sont
associés aussi à des risques accrus de
nombreuses maladies chroniques et
einsteination de l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé donc si vous voulez on a des
coûts cachés très importants ce sont des
calories bon marché à court terme mais à
très long terme il y a un coût très
important pour l'environnement et la
santé et nous avons publié avec Michel
duruc pour 1 euro d'aliments achetés en
Europe c'est 2 euros de coûts cachés
donc en fait c'est très cher à long
terme et enfin la sécurité
socio-économique peut-être menacée car
ces aliments pour vocation plutôt être
consommé de manière isolée et sont
associés à une vie sociale fragmentée
qui ne favorise pas le partage du repas
entre amis en famille en groupe et les
plus pauvres les consommer plus dans les
pays je dis bien occidentaux car ça
n'est pas la même chose dans les pays
émergents développement et donc ils sont
associés à des inégalités sociales de
santé et enfin plus grave ils peuvent
menacer les traditions culinaires et
éloigner les plus jeunes de leur plein
locaux et traditionnels en proposant des
aliments hyper standardisés qui sont à
peu près les mêmes sur toute la planète
des goûts faciles d'accès exacerbés et
qui éloignent des goûts subtiles des
vrais aliments
en conclusion et perspectives en fait
c'est plutôt ma position à moi en tant
que chercheur basé sur mes travaux et si
on est lecture donc je pense que les
approches holistiques et réductionnistes
sont complémentaires et doivent
absolument coexister c'est ce qu'on
appelle finalement la pensée complète et
je pense aussi qu'il faut commencer
d'abord par une approche globale et
holistique et donc commencer à choisir
ses aliments selon le degré de
transformation et non pas les nutriments
et la composition
deuxième point aujourd'hui au vu de
l'urgence a-t-on le temps de tout
décortiquer selon une approche
réductionniste alors le pourquoi est la
causalité est évidemment très important
puisque on a aussi aujourd'hui plus
d'associatifs que de causalité au sens
stricte mais je pense c'est une autre
démarche scientifique donc
réductionniste utile mais sur le plus
long terme et je pense qu'elle n'est pas
à 100% indispensable pour encourager à
déjà réduire leur consommation ce qui a
d'ailleurs été proposé dans le dernier
PNLS puisqu'on propose une réduction de
20%
car si on identifie une partie de
l'ensemble qui est délétère pour qu'elle
amélioration pour la société est-ce que
c'est reformuler des aliments ultra
transformés et remplacer un additif par
un autre marqueur ultra transformation
et je répète selon l'approche holistique
pour moi c'est le tout qui pose problème
et pas une partie du tout et le temps
perdu ne sera pas rattrapera pas en
troisième point je pense que nous avons
suffisamment de preuves aujourd'hui ou
de convergence d'indices pour appliquer
le principe de précaution je rappelle
qu'il y a plus de 100 études
épidémiologiques ce qui prouve aussi que
de nombreux chercheurs indépendants dans
le monde ont été capables d'identifier
ces aliments donc plus de 25% sont plus
robustes c'est-à-dire longitudinal
il y a un double effet ubiquitaire qui
est très intéressant à souligner c'est
que les faits sur les maladies
chroniques et le même quel que soit les
populations sur la planète donc ça veut
dire que il y a un effet presque
générique délétère de ces aliments
lorsqu'ils sont consommés en quantité
au-delà de l'environnement des
populations et de nombreuses fonctions
de l'organisme semblent toucher
quatrième point je soulignerai qu'il
existe une mise en place opérationnelle
au niveau des transformateurs artisans
industriels de la restauration
collective des professionnels de santé
des consommateurs pour reconnaître et
réduire les aïtés c'est le projet auquel
je participe depuis 2017 qui est
l'indice
pour les technologues sur des basses
cette fois-ci holistiques et sur la
définition qu'un aliment sain et le
moins transformé possible et bien je
pense qu'il faut maintenant faire des
aliments moins transformés en respectant
les matrices alimentaires en respectant
la complexité de l'aliment donc avec une
meilleure qualité matricielle et je
conclurai définitivement disant que tout
ce que je vous ai présenté aujourd'hui
cette approche très empirique inductive
et holistique a été conceptualisé dans
la règle des 3V vrai végétales variés
pour le grand public et qui a fait
l'objet d'une dizaine d'articles
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci beaucoup pour votre exposé très
très riche j'ai passé maintenant à la
parole à Madame Mathilde Touvier
l'écran faut que j'appuie sur quoi
voilà merci de votre attention
bonjour
alors je vous prie de m'excuser puisque
ma caméra ne semble pas fonctionner
j'espère que le partage d'écran
fonctionnera qu'à l'important et que
vous voyez les diapositives oui oui ça
fonctionne très bien
alors
voyez le diapositive
oui oui nous voyons
merci
je passerai très rapidement sur les
premières diapositives je ne savais pas
exactement ce que Monsieur fardeau
présenterait mais il a fait une
présentation assez complète de la
définition la question qu'on se pose ici
d'un point de vue scientifique et impact
santé c'est finalement
malgré donc tous les progrès évidents de
la transformation des aliments au fil
des siècles et qui ont apporté des un
certain bénéfice bénéfice microbiologie
praticité d'utilisation accessibilité
etc comme la rappeler Anthony fardey
la question étant aller plus loin
finalement y a-t-il des caractéristiques
propres assez aliment ultra transformés
qui font qu'il peut y avoir de manière
plausible et causale un impact sur la
santé à la fois cardiométabolique cancer
ou autre pathologies chroniques mais ces
questions là on se pose de parler
caractéristiques de ces aliments extra
transformés leur
composition nutritionnelle puisque ce
sont effectivement en moyenne alors ça
reste une moyenne c'est pas vrai pour
l'ensemble des produits mais en moyenne
des aliments à plus forte teneur en
sucre en sel moins de fibres de
vitamines minéraux etc
mais aussi ce sont des produits qui
contiennent généralement effectivement
des additifs alimentaires donc pour
certains se posent des questions sur le
l'impact santé à long terme avec des
études des sonnettes d'alarme finalement
qui ont été tirés par certaines études
plutôt expérimentales donc in vitro ou
une vivo encore peu d'études chez
l'homme pour le moment mais justement
les premiers résultats commencent à
sortir maintenant et puis d'autres
ingrédients à tout ce qui est huile
hydrogénée avec la projection de
production d'acides gras trans des
différences sirops de sucre de maïs de
glucose etc les contaminants qui peuvent
être liés aux procédés de transformation
eux-mêmes ou bien encore provenant des
matériaux d'emballage et puis l'aspect
effectivement aussi modification de la
matrice alimentaire
donc effectivement les études portant
sur les liens avec la santé ont été
basés pour la plupart au niveau
international sur la classification Nova
qui a été présentée et donc je passerai
rapidement là-dessus pour gagner un
petit peu de temps et on s'intéresse
vraiment à des aliments qui donc ont
subi d'importants procédés de
transformation à la fois physique ou
chimique donc prétraitement par friture
hydrolyse extrusion etc et également des
aliments qui contiennent différents
types de substances comme certains
additifs alimentaires pour lesquels
l'impact santé peut être questionné ou
d'autres substances on voit ici pour
compléter la présentation qui vient
d'être faite la différence entre
l'aliment finalement brut donc nous va 1
ici une banane par exemple et le sont
pendant on va dire ultra transformé qui
a le la forme l'odeur le goût de la
banane mais avec pas un gramme de banane
dedans et uniquement des composants qui
caractérise vraiment en tant que
quasiment ultra transformé rappel là
également on adhère tout à fait donc à
cette idée là c'est très important de le
rappeler tous les produits industriels
ne sont pas forcément ultra transformés
là on a deux exemples de soupe l'une
finalement avec une composition qui est
tout à fait similaire à celle que l'on
aurait si on le faisait si on disait
finalement à la maison et c'est pourtant
un aliment complètement industriel et
ici au contraire une une composition de
produits qui avec un premier ingrédient
qui est sirop de glucose déshydraté donc
complètement ultra transformé
donc le en termes de part dans les
études épidémiologiques de l'apport
énergétique apporté par les ultras
transformés on est nous un apport à peu
près on va dire au milieu des pays avec
entre 30 et 35% d'après l'étude ens donc
représentative la population française
et on était autour de on est autour de
57 58% plutôt pour les États-Unis par
exemple pour donner un comparatif donc
on s'est intéressé aux liens entre
aliments ultra transformés et santé au
sein de l'accord nutrinette santé
on a donc cette courbe nutrinat de santé
c'est une étude que nous avons lancée en
2009 qui est la première web cohort de
cette taille dans le monde sur les
relations nutrition santé et qui réunit
aujourd'hui plus de 173.000 adultes
participants et donc c'est participant
nous remplissent très régulièrement des
des questionnaires notamment des
enregistrements alimentaires de 24
heures validées pour mesurer donc leur
comportement alimentaire et donc ça ça
permet une très fine très détaillée de
tout ce qui est exposition liée à
l'alimentation on mesure évidemment tout
un tas d'autres paramètres liés au
comportement au mode de vie tabagisme le
prise de médicaments exposition solaire
dans tout un ensemble de paramètres qui
vont être importants pour ajuster nos
modèles et pour justement prendre en
compte ces différences de comportements
associés et également aux consommations
alimentaires et aux risques de
pathologies et ensuite évidemment dans
le temps les participants c'est une
cohort donc on a depuis le démarrage
plus de 13 ans de suivi maintenant et
donc plus de 5000 cas de cancers qui
sont apparus 2600 maladies
cardiovasculaires et donc d'autres cas
de pathologies avec un comité médical
qui valide ces événements de santé et
également un lien avec les bases de
l'assurance maladie
donc c'est vraiment un outil qui permet
d'aller vraiment au finesse dans la
formation qu'on collecte sur les
aliments et c'est important ici pour
pour dire qu'on a vraiment les
informations nécessaires qui permettent
de bien caractériser les aliments pris
et donc de les classer en aliments plus
ou moins ultra transformés et même
d'aller plus loin vous le verrez dans
les perspectives sur le la
caractérisation de la composition en
additif des produits avec aussi la
possibilité de scanner des aliments avec
le code barre qui pour les participants
et donc d'avoir un lien notamment avec
la base open food fax avec toute la
composition la composition des produits
la teneur en additif etc la présence
d'additif
donc voilà ce que nous avons observé
dans le cas de l'étude nutrinat de santé
je vous montrerai pas l'ensemble des
tableaux de chiffres ou de graphes pour
l'ensemble des pathologies mais ils sont
dans le diaporama que vous aurez à
disposition ensuite voici l'étude
portant sur le diabète de type 2 où l'on
voit ici finalement une relation entre
la part d'aliments ultra transformés
dans le régime alimentaire et
l'augmentation au fil du suivi du risque
de diabète avec une augmentation ici
dans cette étude qui était quasi
linéaire plus la part d'ultra
transformée dans le régime augmenté plus
le risque de diabète de type 2 au cours
du suivi augmenter également
même chose pour ce qui était des
trajectoires de poids et de l'incident
de l'apparition de surpoids et d'obésité
vous voyez ici des courbes
d'augmentation de poids au cours du
suivi selon les groupes de consommation
d'aliments ultra transformés et donc ici
la courbe en violet celle qui a la plus
forte augmentation de poids au cours du
suivi était les participants qui avaient
le plus fort la plus part d'aliments
ultra transformés dans le régime
alimentaire et vous voyez ici également
l'augmentation du risque de devenir en
surpoids et du risque de devenir obèse
au cours du suivi qui augmente avec la
part du train transformé dans le régime
alimentaire
alors encore une fois je donnerai pas le
détail mais pour vous montrer qu'on a
également montré les liens avec le
risque de cancer au global et notamment
cancer du sein dans cette étude même
chose avec le risque de maladies
cardiovasculaire à la fois maladie donc
que la radiation globale maladie
coronarienne maladie cérébrovasculaire
comme le l'avait fait par exemple des
liens également avec le la mortalité au
fil du suivi avec le risque de symptômes
dépressif mesuré par des échelles
validées et répétés de symptômes
dépressifs et également un lien cette
fois-ci avec une étude transversale sur
avec les troubles fonctionnels digestifs
donc pour synthétiser ce que nous avons
trouvé dans l'étude nutrinat de santé
c'est donc le fait que une consommation
accrue d'aliments ultra transformés
c'est associé à un risque accru de
cancer maladies cardiovasculaires
mortalité troubles gastro-intestinaux
symptômes dépressif diabète de type 2 et
sur quoi obésité donc ça a été publié
dans des grands journaux qui ont fait
l'objet de multiples pires view donc
vraiment des revues très très
importantes qui nous ont aussi beaucoup
de challenges donc il y a énormément
d'analyses de sensibilité dans ces
articles qui montrent la robustesse de
ces résultats et avec évidemment la
prise en compte de tout un ensemble de
facteurs liés au mode de vie à
l'activité physique au tabagisme à côté
des participants tout ça et évidemment
pris en compte dans ses études là et
donc ça a permis notamment de d'intégrer
le fait de limiter les Ultra transformés
dans le Programme National Nutrition
Santé officiellement maintenant donc ces
résultats dans nutrinette santé ont été
synthétisés dans les cahiers nutrition
éducététiques vous pouvez trouver la
synthèse en français ici et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que à l'heure actuelle
avant qu'on commence à travailler
là-dessus donc en 2018 d'un point de vue
étiologique dans nutrinette il n'y avait
que quelques études dans le monde et
donc portant uniquement sur discipidémie
variation de poids donc études
prospective où on suit les participants
dans le temps pour mesurer l'apparition
des maladies et vous voyez depuis le
développement très important des
recherches au niveau international qui
sont venus confirmer pour beaucoup les
résultats qu'on a observés dans nutrinat
de santé sur certains sur certaines
pathologies et qui en ont étudié
également d'autres et voyez ici plus de
50 études prospectives qui aujourd'hui
montrent ces relations entre animal très
transformés et santé on a synthétisé
l'ensemble de ses preuves fin de ses
études
épidémiologiques dans un article du
landset gastronautologie et pathologies
cette ce qui a été publié cet été et qui
fait également une synthèse sur les
mécanismes notamment sur l'impact au
niveau du microbiote intestinal donc il
y a également des méta-analyses donc des
résumés chiffrés finalement de toutes
ces études épidémiologiques qui ont été
publiées vous voyez ici donc les
références pour le pour votre rapport on
a donc évidemment pas la possibilité
lorsqu'on pressend comme c'est le cas
ici d'un impact délétère ici de la
consommation d'aliments écrasé sur la
santé de mettre en place qu'on appelle
des essais contrôlés endomisés à long
terme sur où on donnerait pendant des
années des ultras transformés à un de
personnes des aliments sains entre
guillemets à un autre groupe de
personnes et puis on regarde qui meurt
le plus vite qui a le plus de cancers
etc évidemment éthiquement c'est
totalement impossible de faire ce type
d'études en revanche des essais à très
court terme qui ne mettent pas en danger
la vie des participants sont possibles
et donc il y a eu notamment un essai de
la part de l'équipe de Kevin hall qui a
montré que déjà 15 jours il y avait un
impact sur le métabolisme sur la prise
de poids dans le cadre d'un essai
randomisé avec l'utilisation d'aliments
ultra transformés donc maintenant en
termes de perspective ce qu'on est en
train de faire depuis maintenant
quelques deux trois ans c'est de creuser
finalement de tirer les ficelles de
cette pelote complexe que sont les
aliments ultra transformés pour essayer
de comprendre les liens de cause à effet
qui peut y avoir puisque là on parle
d'études majoritairement d'observation
le fait qu'elle soit si nombreuse et
cohérente sont des arguments importants
en faveur de la causalité mais pour
vraiment conclure à une association
causale il faut aller plus loin dans la
compréhension justement des mécanismes
qui peut y avoir derrière et donc
effectivement on a un gros projet de
recherche notamment financé par l'Europe
par l'insuffisance du cancer ministère
de la Santé qui permet de de creuser ces
aspects donc est-ce que ça vient des
additifs quels additifs seuls en
cocktail des matériaux de contact des
faits sur la matrice des contaminants
liés au procès etc donc notamment pour
ce qui est des additifs le projet
financé par le RC additive permet de
permettre vraiment de creuser ces
aspects là la chance qu'on a dans
nutrinat de santé c'est qu'on a accès à
une information très fine sur les
aliments y compris le nom et la marque
des produits ce qui permet ici vous
voyez sur les biscuits de d'avoir ce
niveau de détails que non pas les autres
études au niveau international et de
pouvoir aller jusqu'à la composition en
additif donc on a pu
ces travaux sont publiés également entre
pas dans le détail ici mais on a pu
regarder quels étaient au niveau de
cette large population française les
additifs les plus consommés qu'elles
étaient les cocktails des mélange
d'additifs également les plus
fréquemment consommés et on étudie
maintenant les liens avec le les
pathologies chroniques donc avec des
premiers travaux publiés ici sur nitrite
Nitrat et risque de cancer en montrant
une augmentation de risque liée à
l'utilisation de ces additifs un lien
également entre consommation
d'édulcorant intense et risque de cancer
publié au printemps cette année et
également il y a 15 jours dans le BMJ
l'article sur les maladies
cardiovasculaires à la fois pour
l'aspartame assez sulfamcas sucralose
donc là aussi ce sont des études qui
bien entendu méritent confirmation dans
d'autres populations et également des
travaux expérimentaux pour pouvoir
vraiment établir un niveau de preuve et
un lien de causalité mais qui commence
justement à apporter des pierres à
l'édifice sur cette compréhension des
aliments ultra transformés leur impact
santé donc de plus en plus de preuves
épidémiologiques des résultats à
confirmer mais finalement suffisamment
de d'éléments pour que les pouvoirs
publics et décidé d'inclure ces aliments
être à transformer dans les recomm c'est
le cas en France au Brésil en Israël
dans différents pays et dans un rapport
également de la FAO et finalement un
levier d'action et l'information des
consommateurs qui peut passer par
justement les questions d'étiquetage il
faut vraiment avoir en tête cette vision
trois dimensions de l'alimentation et
donc c'est ma dernière diapos je
conclurai là-dessus il y a l'aspect
nutritionnel donc là le fait que manger
trop gras trop sucré trop sales et pas
assez de fibres etc ça ça ait des effets
délétères sur le cardiométabolique les
cancers toutes ces pathologies
chroniques ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est très prouvé et donc pour
cela le nutriscor apporte cette
information sur la qualité
nutritionnelle globale des aliments il y
a tout l'aspect qu'on n'aborde pas ici
mais l'aspect lié au contaminant lié au
mode de
production donc les pesticides donc là
on a le logo agriculture biologique est
déjà présent donc sur éclairer les
consommateurs sur cette dimension là ce
qui est actuellement à l'étude donc on
est en train de conduire justement un
essai endomisé dans nutrinette pour
tester cela ce serait d'ajouter une
mention graphique notamment une
nutriscor par exemple avec un cadre noir
donc c'est un prototype il peut y avoir
plein de d'autres solutions à graphiques
et qui permettrait d'indiquer si
l'aliment est ou non ultra transformé
donc un cadre lorsqu'il est ultra
transformé au pas-de-cadre sinon au
consommateurs de manière à ce qu'il est
sur l'emballage l'ensemble des
informations pour prendre une décision
éclairée par rapport à l'impact sur la
santé de des aliments qu'ils
consommaient je vous remercie pour votre
attention évidemment c'est les travaux
de l'ensemble d'une équipe et je reste à
votre disposition pour les questions
merci beaucoup pour ce bel exposé je
passe la parole maintenant à Madame
Véronique Brasco
à vous
oui vous m'entendez
oui très bien oui voilà bonjour donc je
vais essayer de partager mon écran
c'est bon vous voyez quelque chose
[Musique]
nous pouvons explicitement la notion de
transformation d'aliments donc de
technologie alimentaire et on ne peut
que s'étonner je crois de voir à quel
point les technologues de l'alimentation
particuliers les chercheurs dans cette
discipline sont relativement absents des
débats que nous avons alors que ce sont
eux qui connaissent le plus finement les
les aliments et je pense que ce serait
important de les
de les convoquer dans ces débats alors
sans répertorier tous les aspects les
bénéfices de la transformation des
aliments sur lesquels je pense personne
ne revient il est clair que tous nos
aliments proviennent de matières
premières qui sont transformées et
assemblées pour aboutir par exemple à
une pizza le blé va être transformé en
farine puis en pâte la tomate en purée
puis on sauce etc etc là où les choses
se compliquent c'est que
l'intensité et la complexité de chacune
de ces transformations est variable
depuis par exemple une mouture dans une
meule de pierre de farine jusqu'à
l'obtention d'une farine blanche dans
laquelle on va réintroduire des
fractions perdues lors du raffinage des
fibres par exemple
de façon à obtenir des produits plus
standardisés on peut aussi ajouter des
des additifs à la farine par exemple
pour m'avoir une meilleure comportement
des pâtes par exemple etc etc donc on
voit que on va donc aboutir à des
produits dont le degré de transformation
peut être extrêmement extrêmement
variable en particulier quand il y a de
nombreuses matières premières de
nombreux ingrédients qui eux-mêmes
chacun auront pu subir des traitements
différents d'intensité d'intensité
différentes ce que nous a plus ou moins
montré Anthony vardet donc on voit qu'en
fait il va y avoir des aliments qui vont
être plus ou moins transformés dont
certains sont peuvent sans doute être
qualifiés de d'hyper ou d'ultra
transformés mais on voit surtout qu'il
va s'agir de continuum et pas d'une
catégorisation
noir blanc
ultra transformé nom du nom ultra
transformé à partir de là la question
qui qui peut nous occuper même si les
présentations précédentes on
suggéré qu'il y avait pas de questions
autour de autour de la classification
c'est quand même à mon sens de définir
vraiment scientifiquement ce que sont
les aliments ultra transformés de façon
à pouvoir manier ce concept d'une
manière la plus rigoureuse possible et
en particulier de pouvoir sans ambiguïté
classer un aliment selon ce
transformation
donc scientifiquement parlant une
classification c'est une méthode donc
elle doit être validée comme tout outil
scientifique répondre à des critères de
qualité voilà il y a des choses qui
parlent de reproductibilité de
robustesse etc et aujourd'hui
je pense que on peut s'interroger sur la
clarté et le caractère opérationnel de
la définition des aliments ultra
transformés que nous avons et sur la
validité méthodologique des outils de
classification qui sont qui sont
proposés et en particulier pour la
classification Nova qui vous l'avez
compris et de loin la plus la plus
utilisée donc nous avons mené avec
certains collègues du secteur public un
travail spécifique sur la classification
Nova qui a récemment été publiée et nous
avons montré dans ce dans ce travail que
il y avait une grande d'été rogénéité
dans les classifications opérées par des
professionnel de l'alimentation et nous
avons interrogé à peu près
160 personnes et vous voyez ici sur
l'une des listes de produits que nous
avons
testé que
90 donc à peu près de 3/4 des aliments
étaient majoritairement classés en
novakat ce qui correspond aux aliments
ultra transformés donc 90% c'est une
majorité très significative mais c'est
quand même pas quand même pas 100% donc
tout le monde n'était pas forcément
forcément d'accord et surtout un quart
un quart des aliments était classé de
manière beaucoup plus hétérogène parfois
en deux classes comme ici ou parfois
même de manière beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus répartie sur sur quatre
classes donc la concordance entre les
évaluateurs en quelque sorte la
corrélation s'établit à 0,32 ce qui est
relativement relativement faible en
particulier pour un outil de ce type là
la concordance parfaite serait de 1 donc
vous voyez qu'on est relativement
relativement loin et lorsqu'on travaille
avec un système de classification qui
repose un algorithme sur quelque chose
de structuré de chiffrer on aboutit à
des coefficients qui sont proches de là
ou qui sont égaux il y en a un si on
faisait ça par exemple avec du
nutriscore à moins de faire des erreurs
de calcul on serait on serait à 0,99
donc ça peut s'expliquer en particulier
par le fait que Nova les critères de
Nova et les critères des classifications
qui existent aujourd'hui ne sont pas
organisées en algorithme ou en
logigramme non ambigu les critères
également sont relativement par exemple
sur les sur les yaourts que nous avons
inclus dans la liste que je vous montre
ici en fait quand on selon la façon dont
on interprète les critères de Nova dont
les hiérarchises les uns par rapport aux
autres et bien on peut classer un yaourt
nature non sucré soit on nous va un donc
pas transformé du tout ou très peu en
Nova 3 majeur légèrement transformés ou
transformer ou en novaka transforme on a
donc un outil qui peut être
considéré comme non robuste parce que la
classification dépend dépend de
l'opérateur donc ça c'est relativement
ennuyeux pour un outil pour un outil
scientifique et c'est le cadre
vraisemblablement de toutes les
classifications à distance
sauf peut-être même si c'est un petit
peu
prématuré d'une classification qui est
issue d'un travail français en cours qui
mené par Isabelle Souchon de l'inrae que
je vous conseille vivement de d'entendre
il s'agit d'un score qui évalue le degré
de transformation des aliments en
fonction de des
procédés thermiques chimiques ou
biologiques etc qui ont été qui ont été
utilisés et qui dotent chaque produit
d'un score chiffré selon un algorithme
qui est bien structuré alors c'est une
méthode qui n'est pas encore aboutie ni
validée mais elle fournit une approche
scientifique objective à partir de
laquelle on peut de travailler
sérieusement même si ce n'est
effectivement qu'un début alors on peut
se dire aussi bah finalement que la pour
ne pas de méthode vraiment validée
reconnue c'est peut-être pas si grave si
grave que ça voilà bon tant que
scientifique ça me gêne quand même ça me
gêne quand même un petit peu d'abord
parce que même si cela ne remet pas en
cause l'intérêt de s'interroger sur les
effets de la transformation des aliments
et sur leur santé et ça ne remet
vraisemblablement pas en cause ce qui
vous a été montré dans son
dans son dans son essence forcer de
constater que ces travaux sont menés sur
une classification qui ne répond pas à
des critères scientifiques très basiques
je pense que tout le travail de l'erat
et d'extrêmement bonne qualité il m'a
t-il de tout vivre nous l'a bien montré
à ce point près qui pour moi est un
point faible donc ça lance cela peut
entraîner des incohérences quand même
comme l'a montré un travail récent qui a
été fait sur une autre cote que la
cohorte nutrinette mais avec une
méthodologie qui dont on va dire
globalement qu'elle est voisine donc
c'est une corde avec des recueils de de
consommation alimentaire et les
chercheurs ont regardé qualité
l'association entre
les marqueurs des marqueurs
cardiométaboliques et l'augmentation de
la consommation d'aliments ultra
transformée pardon de 5%, selon qu'ils
étaient déterminés par Nova ou par trois
autres classifications sur lesquelles
j'ai pas le temps de m'étendre et qui
sont moins connus et beaucoup moins
utilisés que Nova dont on va dire
qu'elles sont ni pires ni pire ni
meilleure et vous voyez ici que on n'a
pas toujours les mêmes on n'a pas
toujours des associations
significatives de la même façon donc
certaines classifications vont mettre en
évidence certains liens avec avec le
les marques cardio métaboliques et
d'autres ne vont ne vont pas mettre en
évidence les mêmes associations sur les
même sur les mêmes marqueurs ce qui est
potentiellement un petit peu voilà en
tout cas qui pose qui pose question
alors d'autre part je pense que cette
classification Nova et son ambiguïté ne
permet pas non plus d'explorer très
scientifiquement les raisons de rien
avec la santé ça n'empêche pas et
Mathilde de Touvier l'a dit de d'avoir
identifié les différents paramètres et
de les étudier séparément mais on a plus
on a des difficultés à on va avoir des
difficultés à savoir quel
mécanisme est
le plus important dans tel ou tel dans
tel ou tel cas de figure en gros si le
lien avec la santé existe est-ce qu'il
est dû à la texture des aliments qui va
pouvoir modifier effectivement leur
vitesse d'ingestion leur caractère à
sasiant et aussi leur métabolisme est-ce
que c'est duel présence d'additive
est-ce que c'est du ou caractéristique
national la tractivité même elle a
facilité dans le pot avoir au marketing
qui sont des points qui n'ont pas été
relevés par par Mathilde et tout dit
Anthony Fardin mais qui sont pourtant
présents dans la classification Nova
et quel est quel élément est
prépondérant puisqu'en fait un aliment
ultra transformé va pouvoir être
transformé pour une ou plusieurs de ces
différentes de ces différentes raisons
donc les classifications actuelles en
fait elles n'aident pas beaucoup
à comprendre
ce qui ce qui se passe il serait sans
doute beaucoup plus intéressant de
pouvoir
s'intéresser à ce qui se passe à
améliorer les transformations les
transform sur les points qui doivent
l'être en fonction des produits sans
tout sans tout jetés sont tout jetés aux
orties comme ce qui est souvent un petit
peu
proposé ou en tout cas compris une autre
faiblesse conceptuelle je pense de ces
classifications et de la classification
Nova en particulier c'est que elle ne
permet pas de rendre compte de ce
continuum dont je vous parlais du niveau
de transformation un aliment est ultra
transformé où il ne l'est pas on n'a pas
de score chiffré comme c'est le cas
d'une nutriscore où il y a quand même
non seulement beaucoup plus de
catégories mais surtout en continuant à
me chiffrer
un score chiffré qui est beaucoup plus
beaucoup beaucoup plus fin ou le score
de Processing dont je vous dont je vous
parlais donc en fait ça limite beaucoup
les possibilités pour un industriel de
savoir sur quelle partie de son de son
ultra transformation entre guillemets il
peut jouer et ça n'aide pas non plus
beaucoup le consommateur pour choisir
entre plusieurs niveaux de
transformation alors on peut
effectivement mettre une un bandeau noir
sous le nutriscore il y a certaines
catégories de produits sur lesquels avec
les classifications actuelles on va
toujours avoir du noir donc ça veut dire
que ce type de produit on ne doit plus
le consommer et ça peut poser
effectivement un certain nombre de
problèmes en particulier là où je pense
que ça devient problématique c'est que
on a un risque de confusion qui devient
aujourd'hui très fréquent pas forcément
dans les dans les dans les sénates le
scientifiques mais en tout cas au niveau
des des consommateurs et des médias
entre aliments ultra transformés égal
aliments produits par l'industrie et
donc aliment produit par l'industrie
égale aliment dangereux dangereux pour
la santé je pense que c'est un raccourci
facile probablement dangereux et à mon
avis excessif et qu'il n'est pas très
responsable d'entretenir donc je pense
que là la première la seconde partie de
cette table ronde abordera peut-être les
conséquences économiques et
sociologiques de ces de ces points de
vue mais il me semble que voilà c'est
pas la meilleure chose qu'aujourd'hui on
puisse faire et enfin si on envisage des
à mesure de santé publique ou même des
réglementations dans le domaine des
ultras transformés il va falloir doter
d'un outil plus solide et plus rigoureux
et moins attaquables que les
classifications existantes parce que de
manière très très pratique on s'expose à
des discussions et probablement à des
contentieux sont fins sur la la
classification de tel ou tel de tel ou
tel aliment voilà donc en conclusion je
pense que il y a très probablement
quelque chose quelque chose à examiner
autour de la relation entre les aliments
ultra transformés la santé mais que les
outils actuels de classification à mon
sens ne permettent pas de le faire de
façon de façon objective et optimale il
faudrait revenir à une démarche
scientifique en tout cas sur la sur la
classification qui permettrait d'être
plus serein dans ces dans ces débats
voilà je vous remercie de votre
attention et juste bien sûr prête à
répondre à toutes questions sur un
particulier tous les points qui n'est
pas eu le temps de d'aborder
merci beaucoup donc nous allons passer
maintenant au moment des bas c'est à
dire quelques questions d'abord
peut-être de nous les parlementaires et
puis ensuite des internautes donc moi
j'ai personnellement alors suite à votre
intervention c'est vrai que le
questionnement que j'ai pour l'instant
moi personnellement c'est sur le manque
plutôt d'informations des consommateurs
et sur l'ultra transformation parce que
je pense que beaucoup de consommateurs
n'ont même pas conscience de ce qui a
été
mentionné aujourd'hui c'est à dire sur
ces matrices dégradées artificialisées
le fait qu'on craque les aliments et je
pense que déjà il y a un sujet sur
là-dessus ensuite c'est
c'est il y a des aspects ils ont été
mentionnés
multidimensionnels de cette alimentation
ultra transformée
de multiples dimensions peuvent être
difficiles à appréhender pour le
consommateur qui peut notamment avoir du
mal à les hiérarchiser comment informer
efficacement le consommateur sur les
produits alimentaires qu'il consomme et
est-il envisageable vous l'avez un peu
déjà mentionné de construire un logo
alimentaire multidimensionnel et puis je
rajouterai une autre question puis après
je laisserai mes collègues puisqu'il y a
été évoqué les emballages et notamment
qui sont majoritairement en plastique je
ne sais pas si je n’ai pas trop vu ça
apparaissait dans vos études l'impact
des emballages plastiques parce qu'ils
sont au contact direct des aliments et
notamment des aliments gras et on sait
qu'il y a des passages du plastique à
l'aliment de façon très importante donc
voilà c'est le questionnement par
rapport à cela est-ce que dans vos
études vous avez
donc intégré la l'importance peut-être
qui n'a pas pas été suffisamment
envisagée des emballages merci
la prise de parole
pour moi les emballages c'est pas mon
domaine d'accord oui
c'est pas mon domaine non plus je te
laisse parler Mathilde la seule chose
c'est que l'emballage aujourd'hui n'a
pas grand chose à voir avec
transformation non transformation vous
avez des aliments qui sont très peu
transformés qui peuvent également être
emballés on peut emballé dans du
plastique du poisson de la viande qui
sont non transformés donc il y a pas
forcément alors pas forcément de
recoupement
voilà absolue entre présence
d'emballages et présence de plastique et
transformation ultra transformation
ultra transformé avec beaucoup plus de
portions individualisées
oui non mais il y a une durée une durée
de conservation également plus longue en
général ce qui fait que que qu'en fait
les animaux ultra transformés souvent
restent plus longtemps au contact de des
emballages et notamment plastique ou des
concerts etc en moyenne là aussi c'est
comme le la 4e nutritionnel tout ça
c'est en moyenne mais ça reste quand
même une question et impossible une des
pierres encore une fois en fait pour
boucler finalement par rapport à ce que
véronicase expresso présentée
clairement là on a affaire à un ensemble
holistique comme disait Anthony fardey
de de d'aliments donc très divers en
termes de justement de de d'emballage de
matériaux contacts de composition en
matière d'additif etc de transformation
plus ou moins intense voilà donc c'est
sûr que on a affaire une diversité
d'aliments et du coup effectivement se
pose la question d'une définition alors
scientifique j'irai plus loin que ça
c'est réglementaire pour répondre à ce
qui a été effectivement si on veut
pouvoir par exemple agir au niveau de
l'étiquetage et informer sur est-ce que
l'aliment est ultra transformé ou non ou
un autre une autre forme d'information
il va falloir se doter d'une définition
qui soit absolument non ambiguë et je
rejoins du coup Véronique en ce sens-là
et c'est pour ça que du coup on a
insisté pour que notamment l'ancien pour
qui est quand même le mieux placé la
mieux placée agence en France pour pour
faire ça puisse réfléchir à cette
question-là et à une définition qui soit
absolument non ambiguë où il peut y
avoir des annexes enfin quelque chose de
très réglementaire pour pouvoir classer
ces produits là donc ça c'est on est
vraiment en accord avec ça la question
là c'est plus ok il peut y avoir des
petites distinctions des petites parfois
aliments à la frontière où on sait pas
dans quel groupe le classer ou bien des
distinctions selon les classifications
etc mais malgré ça et au contraire
justement la robustesse des résultats
épidémiologiques qui montrent les
associations avec une augmentation de
risque de toutes ces maladies la plus de
50 études prospectives etc
malgré justement ces potentiels
questionnements sur le classement
parfois frontières etc qui ont en
général ont plutôt tendance à brouiller
à atténuer les associations quand on a
des des problèmes de classification
comme ça la robustesse des résultats
enfin voilà nous encourage à dire qu'il
y a vraiment quelque chose qui après si
on veut le décliner en terme de
d'étiquetage etc qui va falloir
travailler sur la définition pour
qu'elle devienne opérationnelle
réglementaire etc ça c'est une certitude
on est d'accord là-dessus mais il faut
faire attention aux messages qu'on
délivre c'est à dire que il faudrait pas
dire bon ben voilà on sait pas très bien
ce qu'il y a derrière du coup finalement
on peut on peut rien faire il y a quand
même assez de d'éléments scientifiques
pour dire qu'il faut agir pour le
consommateur donc ne serait-ce que par
principe de précaution et en attendant
que la recherche progresse sur ben voilà
l'impact des additifs des emballages etc
ce qu'on est en train de faire en même
temps on n'attend pas les on se tournant
les pouces on est en train d'avancer sur
ces aspects et de réunir justement
toutes ces toutes ces éléments
le poids des éléments relatifs
mais en attendant on peut quand même ne
pas pas dire on va attendre 10 ans 15
ans d'avoir fini toutes ces recherches
sur chaque additif chaque matériau de
contact chaque contaminant il faut quand
même informer les consommateurs il faut
quand même agir à ce niveau là donc oui
tout n'est certainement pas parfait mais
suffisamment de d'éléments scientifiques
robustes pour quand même se dire que là
il faut agir il faut faire quelque chose
travailler sur la définition avec une
instance officielle comme l'ancêtre qui
se saisit de la question et
effectivement voilà on recherche on
travaille avec Isabelle Souchon on a
intégré évidemment au courant mais on a
intégré ce fameux score de process dans
la base de données nutrinette on a aussi
les additifs on a les les emballages
avec le scan des aliments on sait quel
que le code barre qu'elle emballage ils
ont pris donc on va vraiment pouvoir
justement étudier le poids relatif le
lycée différents composés etc on a des
premiers résultats mais on va pas
attendre 15 ans d'avoir fini ses
recherches là-dessus pour faire quelque
chose et informer les consommateurs sur
ces risques qui semblent quand même se
dessiner des aliments ultra transformés
en complément très très brève juste pour
la définition je voulais rappeler aussi
qu'on avait eu le même problème avec la
définition de ce qu'on appelle allwrence
les céréales complètes qui a évolué qui
était qualitative aussi assez qualitatif
ce qui n'a pas empêché de faire
l'épidémiologie sur cette définition
avec des associations entre céréales
complètes et
on était un peu dans le même problème
[Musique]
on peut quand même souligner que plus de
100 études épidémiologiques il y a quand
même ça veut dire qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de chercheurs dans le monde
entier plutôt indépendants qui quand
même ont réussi à classer et je rejoins
tout à fait ma petite touiller dans ce
qui est dit et pour la définition je
pense peut-être ce qui manque c'est une
liste exhaustive de ce que nous on a
appris avec Cigale et marqueurs ultra
transformation pour avoir quelque chose
de plus précis et en tout cas nous on a
développé cette liste de notre côté mais
c'est vrai qu'il faudrait une liste je
pense exhaustive de tout ce qu'on
appelle soit les agents cosmétiques ou
les marqueurs ultra transformation
juste un petit mot pour pour compléter
pour moi le bon ben smark avec une
classification de base c'est peut-être
le nutrisccor qui a été qui a mis quand
même un certain temps à ce à se mettre
en place et qui est un outil qui fait
qui a choisi une certaine liste de
marqueurs et qu'il est qui les a
combinés avec des pondérations qui sont
différentes c'est pas simplement une
question de lys une question de
pondération qu'est-ce qui très important
ou plus ou moins ça va il faudra
certainement faire des discussions et
voilà le nutriscor peut encore être
discuté mais il est globalement
consensuel il faudrait arriver à la même
chose et je pense qu'aujourd'hui mettre
sur ta diapositive Mathilde il y avait
vraiment les
un logo noir en fonction de la
classification Nova honnêtement
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est pas c'est
pas très raisonnable ni responsable de
vouloir travailler avec la
classification Nova telle qu'elle est je
suis d'accord il faut pas attendre 10 ou
15 ans mais il faut quand même faire des
choses qui soient relativement
relativement sérieuses et qui permettent
également de progresser si l'objectif si
infini ça veut dire que on ne peut plus
quasiment rien acheter comme elle qui a
été transformé un petit peu au-delà
d'une cuisson c'est un peu je pense que
c'est ennuyeux à de nombreux titres
je reviens juste justement sur ce que
sur cette remarque enfin faut faire
attention aussi dans la manière dont on
communique c'est pas parce qu'il y a un
mauvais nutri-score d'un côté ou bien un
une information sur ultra transformer
qui que le message est ne plus consommer
enfin faut vraiment aussi avoir je pense
qu'on est tous d'accord là-dessus mais
c'est vrai qu'on fait des raccourcis de
langage parfois c'est juste informer le
consommateur pour dire bon ben voilà on
peut en manger il y a aucun aliment qui
est interdit qu'on mange un aliment
ultra transformé de temps en temps il
nous arrivera rien d'un point de vue
santé pareil si on mange un aliment très
gras sucré salé de temps en temps il y a
pas de problème l'information c'est le
attention il y a des risques potentiels
sur la santé donc c'est pas 3 kg matin
midi et soir c'est plus juste attention
dans la le message qu'il y a derrière et
après alors complètement d'accord sur le
côté
là pour l'instant dans l'état de des
connaissances et si on veut agir des
enfin assez rapidement horizon un an
deux ans pour l'instant tout ce dont on
dispose scientifiquement c'est de ces
nombreuses études qui montre un lien
entre ultra formée globale et santé donc
pour l'instant la formation elle est un
peu dichotomique celle qu'on peut donner
aux consommateurs alors basé sur Nova ou
sur sur une définition affinée voilà
mais après dans quelques années lorsque
on aura identifié finalement sur les 330
additifs probablement que la plupart
n'ont aucun impact délétères sur la
santé on aura peut-être identifié
certains qui posent plus ou moins
problème ou déjà on pourra agir au
niveau réglementation avant de d'agir
sur l'étiquetage on pourra baisser les
doses autorisées etc mais on pourra
affiner cette information qu'on donne
avec justement ce poids relatif des
différentes choses qui posent problème
ou pas mais ça voilà si on attend qu'on
ait fini tous ces la caractérisation de
tout ça on risque d'attendre trop
longtemps et de de louper de la
prévention qu'on pourrait faire entre
temps avec une info qui certes et un
petit peu à la hache on va dire pour
l'instant mais qui du coup est en ligne
est quand même avec cette cinquantaine
d'études prospective centaines quand on
prend aussi les études transversales et
qui montrent des liens ultra transformés
santé donc on est dans une je pense
qu'on est assez d'accord sur sur pas mal
de messages c'est simplement d'un point
de vue action de santé publique
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand
est-ce qu'on attend d'avoir vraiment
tous les éléments on y travaille mais ça
prend quand même un petit peu de temps
ou est-ce que déjà on donne des premiers
messages aux consommateurs même si
sûrement qui sont affinés dans quelques
années parce qu'ils sont basiques par
rapport à l'état des connaissances qu'on
a actuellement je pense que la question
quand même de la de la définition et de
la classification elle va avoir un
impact important sur le nombre de
produits susceptibles de porter ce
logo donc je pense qu'il faut quand même
se donner encore une fois à pas des
années des années mais un petit peu de
temps pour regarder les choses de
manière un peu plus un peu un petit peu
plus subtile je pense
je voulais souligner aussi c'était que
l'ultra transformation c'est vraiment
généralisé après guerre le premier
Arcueil ultra transformation c'est 1811
c'était de la mise en modifier avec de
l'acide sulfurique que c'était très
localisé dans aux États-Unis en
Angleterre et il faut quand même
souligner qu'avec les traitements
traditionnels qu'on utilise depuis la
sédentarisation le néolithique tout ce
qui est thermique fermentaire mécanique
à la au mieux de ma connaissance et de
ce que j'ai pu elle avait pas eu une
telle explosion de maladie chronique
dans le monde il y a quand même un
parallèle entre l'industrialisation
massive de notre alimentation et l'ultra
transformation qui a culminé dans les
années 70-80 et
l'augmentation importante des risques de
maladies chroniques
je pense et puis ce que je voulais
souligner aussi c'est que je suis très
attaché à ça c'est à dire c'est vrai
qu'on est dans une société assez
réductionniste ou on aime décortiquer
c'est utile il faut le faire évidemment
pour notamment améliorer les
connaissances avoir des preuves plus
voilà à long terme mais c'est quand même
c'est l'ensemble qu'il faut questionner
je pense parce que il y A 330 additifs
il y a des plus de 3000 euros en France
tous les nutriments ultra transformés
donc on voit bien qu'il y a des
milliards de combinés des millions de
combinaisons en plus l'aliment est
consommé au scénarisme ça va dépendre
aussi de beaucoup de facteurs donc quand
on va dans la multidimensionnalité la
complexité j'ai peur aussi que ce soit
un processus un peu comme disait
scientifiques elles sans fin vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et vraiment
aujourd'hui au vu d'urgence sanitaire
attend le temps quoi c'est ça moi là qui
me préoccupe en fait
on a également deux autres questions
d'abord Gérard Longuet oui merci
président merci Pierre d'abord je
voudrais vous dire tout le bonheur qu'un
sénateur d'un département
agroalimentaire avec une dominante de
production laitière éprouvée ressent en
entendant les les intervenants et je
remercie
Angèle Préville ma collègue d'avoir mis
ce sujet à l'ordre du jour alors si
j'avais mauvais esprit je dirais que au
début était le Verbe et que le verbe
Ultra est par définition
un verbe négatif par exemple
ultra libéral forcément puisque je suis
libéral on est toujours l'ultra de
quelqu'un donc ça ça rend la la le débat
passionné tant mieux tant mieux comme ça
il est dialectique il est vivant et je
voudrais remercier chacun des trois
intervenants qui m'ont tous les trois
porté des éclairages majeurs à Anthony
fardey je dirais que je partage
totalement son point de vue sur les
logiques qui soutiennent c'est à dire
sur l'aspect infrastructure qu'il a
évoqué
et donc non pas tellement l'impact de
l'alimentation sur la santé mais le
système qu'il représente et j'y
reviendrai parce que je pense que pour
nous élu c'est un sujet majeur et à la
lumière de l'actualité récente c'est
c'est ça reste extraordinairement vivant
madame Touvier nous a montré combien on
devenait sérieux dans l'évaluation des
des conséquences éventuelles de tel ou
tel accès eux pardon de tel ou tel excès
de tel ou telle additif bon c'est pas
encore systématique clair on évoque le
principe de précaution il faudrait pas
entraîner paralysie et Madame briscaux
nous a ramené à une approche peut-être
plus plus empirique plus mesurée et
permettant peut-être l'évolution
nécessaire parce que je reviens
maintenant sur les anciens de ma
conviction c'est que en matière
d'alimentation il faut se souvenir que
la rareté n'est pas très éloignée et que
la rareté peut réapparaître et a même
est en train de réapparaître avec la
crise ukrainienne or le les additifs
dans l'alimentation ont toujours eu pour
origine et les transformations dans
l'alimentation ont toujours eu pour
origine de combattre la rareté en
permettant la pérennité des ressources
alimentaires c'est-à-dire conserver
d'une récolte sur l'autre les capacités
à nourrir les gens qui étaient
nécessaires pour produire et puis aussi
les autres alors c'est c'est d'ailleurs
assez compliqué et disons que cette
rareté aboutit au stockage à l'évolution
industrielle de regarder le fruit le
fruit on peut le prendre sur l'arbre on
peut prendre la pomme c'est d'ailleurs
tous les malheurs d'Adam et Dave et
ensuite on peut le la garder en
confiture on peut la garder en alcool
l'alcool est une façon de garder les
fruits et c'est une immédiatement ça
pose une question culturelle
c'est-à-dire comment consommer l'alcool
les fruits ça va au pire on risque une
diarrhée c'est pas très grave l'alcool
c'est plus préoccupant je veux dire par
là que le stockage puis l'élargissement
des marchés faut bien voir que tant que
le marché
est local et qu'on se déplaçait à pied
voir à cheval ça n'était pas très loin
vous savez par exemple que le chemin de
fer a tué la vigne au nord de la Loire
en France parce qu'il a permis d'élargir
le marché de la vigne du Midi qui était
une vie massive puissante et comme les
curés avait besoin SMS de 20 mai s'il
faisait de la vigne partout et puis la
mauvaise vigne a été chassée par le
chemin de fer pour permettre à une vigne
plus efficace plus généreuse de penser
des fruits donc il y a le stockage il y
a l'élargissement du marché et à partir
du moment où on élargit le marché qui
qui est national qui est continental qui
est aujourd'hui mondial on a des chocs
culturels extrêmement importants
c'est-à-dire que l'attitude vis-à-vis de
la nourriture change complètement par
exemple l'accès aux protéines animales
et quelque chose de relativement ancien
en France selon nous de la poule au pot
d'Henri IV c'est donc la viande est
quand même venue en France plutôt ces
popularisé au 19e et au 20e siècle elle
était rare sur les tables elle accède
maintenant à la Chine et ça modifie les
comportements alimentaires et ça modifie
d'ailleurs la taille des par exemple
l'accès aux protéines animales je crois
dans l'EN en tous les cas dans la
jeunesse modifie l'évolution et la
croissance des gens donc le le choc
enfin le stockage l'élargissement la
diversité de l'offre l'abondance qui
aboutit à une surenchère dans
l'identification dans la diversité des
produits et en effet dans la politique
de marque
peut conduire les uns ou les autres à
modifier les additifs pour flatter des
tendances assez naturelles il y a des
très intéressant sur les additifs sur la
texture il y a des textures qui sont
difficiles à accepter culturellement
dans tel ou tel pays et d'autres qui
sont parfaitement acceptés dans tel ou
telle autre pays il suffit d'avoir
voyagé un petit peu pour se rendre
compte que les textures appréciées ne
sont pas nécessairement les mêmes la
conclusion que que je tire de tout cela
c'est qu'il ne faudrait pas paralyser un
secteur d'activité qui est
extraordinairement créatif et j'ajoute
extraordinairement contrôlée par une un
principe de précaution qui aboutirait à
paralyser toute initiative mais il faut
accepter en revanche une un débat fût-il
conflictuel d'ailleurs c'est pas
tellement gênant les débats constituels
sont souvent les plus riches et les plus
alimentés pour concilier à la fois
la diversité de l'offre la recherche
permanente de produits nouveaux et
naturellement veillez à ce que l'apport
d'additifs extérieur ne puisse pas être
une source
identifiée et affirmée de
de maladies de troubles de santé mais
l'innovation en soi n'est certainement
pas une réponse absolue et l'idée d'une
aide de retrouver la nature est une
parfaite illusion digne de Bouvard et
pécuchait et donc Flaubert a très bien
traité le sujet il y a un siècle il
serait raisonnable de marcher en étant
éclairé par son regard
critique amusant et amusé mais qui ne
m'interdisent pas l'évolution et ce qui
me réjouit dans la démocratie c'est pour
ça que je suis parlementaire et bien
c'est qu'on peut se poser ce type de
questions sans s'enfermer dans des
positions trop théologiques
il y a également une question de
Monsieur brotherson
merci monsieur le Président merci à
notre collègue qui organise cette
audition en fait j'ai deux
questionsnements le premier
il est un peu pragmatique si je vais
faire mes courses que j'achète un steak
une banane et une bouteille de lait a
priori ce ne sont pas des aliments ultra
transformés pourtant les processus
d'élevage
d'agriculture qui ont produit ces
aliments sont
potentiellement
on va dire susceptible d'avoir utilisé
des intrants et des processus qui font
que la qualité de ces aliments jugés non
transformés
devient enfin peut être questionné ça
c'est mon premier questionnement donc
parce que là ça sort du périmètre de ce
qu'on est en train d'étudier ma deuxième
interrogation
elle est tout aussi pragmatique c'est je
me demande aujourd'hui avec les
questions pour d'achat qui sont qui sont
face à nous et dans certains territoires
on est même plus à se poser la question
du pouvoir d'achat mais celle de la
pauvreté
dans le caddie de la ménagère qu'elle va
être le poids du nutri-score du
classement Nova des de tous les labels
qu'on va pouvoir mettre sur les aliments
dans l'acte d'achat est-ce que cet acte
d'achat ne va pas simplement être
conditionnée par le prix tout simplement
et est-ce qu'on va pas est-ce que la
plupart de nos concitoyens ne vont pas
voilà conditionner leur acte d'achat au
prix
je rajouterai également une question des
internautes
des études ont-elles été faites quant à
la part de l'alimentation ultra
transformée dans l'alimentation
infantile quelles sont les impacts de
ces aliments notamment sur les petits
pots assiettes à réchauffer biscuits
donc est-ce qu'il y a des études
spécifiques sur la l'alimentation
infantile
je crois que c'est une étude de riches
collaborateurs il y a un taux de d'ultra
transformation très élevé plus élevé
dans l'alimentation pour enfants que
pour adultes
rappelait que effectivement en France on
est à peu près pour faire simple un
tiers des calories ultra transformé par
jour nous chez les enfants on a évalué
qu'on est 11% plus 46% et ça rejoint des
résultats d'autres pays comme le Brésil
les États-Unis ou effectivement l'offre
alimentaire pour les enfants et toujours
plus ultra transformé que chez les
adultes
c'est une tendance très nette ce qui
tenderait à montrer que les enfants sont
des cibles privilégier des publicités
pour les aliments ultra transformés
d'ailleurs il suffit de regarder la télé
la plupart des aliments vendus pour les
enfants strictement sans quasiment que
l'ultra transformés donc ça c'est c'est
une tendance qu'on observait et puis
pour le prix alors et puis je serai la
parole aux autres je vais être très bref
effectivement les gens disent on n'a pas
le temps on n'a pas d'argent ça c'est
effectivement deux arguments auxquels
ultra transformation répond très bien
c'est-à-dire tout préparé donc on gagne
du temps et des calories souvent bon
marché puisque dans tous les pays où ça
a été mesuré les ultras transformés sont
moins chers que les non ultra
transformés par exemple c'est 5 7% moins
cher en Belgique par rapport au peu
transformé et 64% moins cher aux
États-Unis mais après la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est quelle valeur on
donne à l'alimentation donc c'est à dire
voilà est-ce que c'est le vrai prix des
aliments parce que comme je l'ai
souligné c'est peu cher à l'achat à
court terme mais à très long terme il y
a des coûts cachés très importants pour
la santé publique pour la planète et
pour l'environnement donc il y a une
vraie question de son philosophique
c'est quelle valeur on donne à
l'alimentation et l'alimentation quand
même soutient la vie donc ce qui
soutient la vie est-ce que ça doit être
payé aussi peu cher donc ça c'est une
vraie question et je terminerai en
disant que nous on a calculé en
hypermarché que finalement on pouvait
manger plutôt sain et durable sans
dépenser beaucoup plus qu'un caddie très
riche en produits animaux et ultra
transformés donc il y a aussi une fausse
idée parce que quand on fait des calculs
assez précis on s'aperçoit qu'on peut
aussi quand même manger et végétaliser
davantage sur l'assiette et réduire les
ultras transformés pour un prix à peu
près similaire alors ça demande un peu
d'effort sans doute au début mais c'est
comme pour apprendre à conduire au début
ça demande des efforts et puis après ça
vient tout seul
ça demande aussi de la connaissance à
demande de la connaissance ça demande de
l'éducation et je pense qu'effectivement
voilà beaucoup beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ne l'ont pas et que c'est
aussi un appel pour avoir une essayer
d'avoir une véritable éducation
alimentaire des l'école
voilà je
peux compter peut-être sur les
différents points effectivement sur le
l'histoire de l'alimentation infantile
il y a quelques études prospectives
épidémiologiques qui montrent des liens
alors évidemment on n'est pas là sur des
maladies cardiovasculaires ou cancer etc
on est plus sur des variations de poids
donc prise de poids obésité ou
dyslipidémie donc des régulations
métaboliques qui peuvent plus tard
conduire si elles persistent à des
maladies mais effectivement il y a
plusieurs études longitudinales qui
montrent ces liens d'archers l'enfant
sur l'histoire du prix je rejoins ce qui
vient de dire pas Anthony Faris
c'est-à-dire que si on prend par exemple
tout ce qui est plat préparé ultra
transformés encore une fois tous les
plats industriel du commerce ne sont pas
forcément être à transformer mais
certains le sont ça coûte moins cher
d'acheter un légume de saison des pâtes
complètes et puis soit un morceau de
poisson de viande ou des légumineuses
pour les protéines que d'acheter cette
barquette à 4 euros 5 euros à toute
prête donc là aussi il y a quand même
des on peut manger pas ultra transformer
et sans nutritionnellement et pas si
j'espère que ça après c'est aussi
l'objet justement des discussions
d'aujourd'hui de quelle politique de
prix et quelle politique de gestion met
en place pour permettre l'accès à ces
aliments bons nutritionnellement pas
ultra transformés etc donc c'est parti
de du débat ce qu'on a montré c'est par
exemple aussi avec le nutri-score en
tout cas que pour la question sur le
est-ce que les personnes prennent en
compte ces informations
lorsque ce sont des personnes justement
plus bas revenues etc évidemment le
critère prix apparaît dans les premiers
déterminants des choix mais en tout cas
un système comme le nutriscor ou comme
une information plutôt binaire et simple
à comprendre sur les logos alimentaires
sont sont compris en un impact sur les
intentions d'achat de des personnes
encore plus fortes que dans les on va
dire CSP+ niveau d'éducation plus élevé
etc ou finalement il y a de toute façon
une démarche d'intérêt par rapport à ces
produits et de pouvoir tourner
l'emballage et comprendre un petit peu
la liste de ce qu'il y a derrière et s'y
intéresser donc voilà clairement ces
démarches d'information consommateurs
lorsqu' sont simples et bien véhiculées
peuvent aussi toucher et réduire aussi
les inégalités de santé sur et pour
revenir au premier commentaire voilà qui
était intéressant sur finalement le
paralysé enfin trop en faire trop alerté
et du coup paralyser une certaine
innovation etc évidemment c'est pas le
but c'est à dire qu'on est très content
et on a la chance en France d'avoir
accès à tout un variété de produits
divers très palatables très enfin voilà
d'avoir accès à cette ou cette diversité
là l'idée c'est pas de tout interdire
par contre si on reprend l'exemple des
additifs sur les trois plus de 300 et
quelques quand on aura fini de ces
projets sur les additifs on aura une
bonne idée de ceux qui ne posent aucun
problème ce qui à mon avis vont
représenter la grosse majorité donc là
évidemment on va pas interdire quoi que
ce soit ou jouer quoi que ce soit et si
si les industriels veulent en mettre il
y a pas de problème on aura une idée de
ceux qui posent potentiellement problème
et la question là où ça se pose c'est
que sur les 330 il y en a que une petite
cinquantaine pour lesquelles il y a un
vrai impact positif sur la santé
possible en termes de conservation de
préservation microbiologique etc la
plupart des additifs c'est comme des
additifs dit justement cosmétiques il y
a pas de définition réglementaire de ça
mais en gros qui ne sont là que pour
voilà rendre plus joli plus coloré etc
et donc les utiliser aucun problème s'il
y a pas de problème pour la santé mais
là où ça pose question c'est que ces
additifs pour faire joli si il y a des
risques pour la santé qui commence à
être montré ben là on vient on en vient
un arbitrage entre la santé publique
versus intérêt économique et donc c'est
vraiment cela où là d'un point de vue
gestion du risque se poseront la
question de les interdire ou délimiter
et du coup
juste pour aussi juste rebondir sur deux
choses sur le sur le fait sur le fait du
prix d'un produit d'un plat cuisiné par
rapport à ces ingrédients c'est tout à
fait vrai si on ne regarde que les
ingrédients par contre si on ajoute le
temps qui est nécessaire pour faire pour
pour aller acheter pour euh là il y a il
y a un travail français qui a été fait
il y a quelques il y a quelques mois qui
montre que lorsqu'on ajoute tous ces
tous ces coups induits un petit peu les
coups de l'énergie mais également le
coup du temps ça veut dire qu'en fait
quelqu'un qui travaille n'a juste pas le
temps de faire ça donc c'est un petit
peu je pense qu'il y a une dimension un
peu culpabilisante en disant mais
finalement on sait pas plus cher
faites-le oui mais voilà comment dans la
réalité je le fais il y a un dernier
point aussi c'est que quand même même si
on a fait beaucoup de progrès sur
l'égalité homme-femme je pense que quand
même dans la pratique si on achète des
ingrédients si on fait la cuisine dans
la majorité des cas ça va rester voilà
ça ça va rester
l'apanage des femmes et je pense que il
faudrait faire attention à éviter que ça
ne soit que ça ne soit le cas et l'autre
point sur les additifs et sur le fait
que certains additifs sont cosmétiques
et autres je pense que c'est là que nous
aurions vraiment besoin d'avoir une
connaissance fine de la technologie des
aliments parce que bien sûr les additifs
cosmétiques les colorants ok mais en
fait il y a beaucoup d'additifs qui ne
sont pas des conservateurs et qui sont
également importants pour la fabrication
de l'aliment voilà pour des tas de des
tas de de
considérations qui sont effectivement
industrielles mais qui sont celles qui
permettent d'avoir l'aliment donc je
pense vraiment que là où je pense que ni
Anthony ni Mathilde ni moi ne sommes
détenus nous sommes des technologues et
qu'il faudrait vraiment voilà à demander
ça et d'autre part Mathilde je crains
qui est bien plus que 330 additifs sur
la liste sur la liste européenne je
crois qu'il y en a mis
c'est les additifs c'est 330 après y
aller tous les les auxiliaires
analogiques et puis il y a les arômes
donc c'est d'autres réglementaires ça
pose aussi question sur le lien avec la
santé mais en tout cas additif au sens
strict c'était les 330 moi je rejoins
ton commentaire sur le temps qui est
notre notre problème quotidien à tous
personne qui travaille et donc femme
comme homme d'ailleurs et c'est une
vraie une bonne question et je vais
faire quelque chose que je fais jamais
parce que en tant qu'épidémiologie je
fais jamais d'études sur une personne
mais je prends mon exemple depuis que je
me suis intéressé au niveau recherche
assez question justement d'additive
ultra transformation etc et au risque
potentiels voilà j'ai fait justement cet
exercice au quotidien d'essayer de voir
si avec pas plus de temps parce que les
quotidiens sont extrêmement tendus et
femme avec enfant etc on n'a pas le
temps de passer du temps en cuisine on a
plus le temps de ça on peut complètement
manger très rapidement
et pas ultra transformé et
nutritionnellement bon je dis avec des
compris des initiatives industrielles un
des des légumes surgelés par exemple
dans le PNS on a le droit de consommer
des légumes surgelés ça fait partie des
portions des des pâtes ça fait quand
même quelques minutes à cuire on peut
faire autre chose pendant ce temps mais
pas de complète enfin il y a quand même
des choses qui sont très faciles à
cuisiner au quotidien très rapide et qui
sont nutritionnellement très
intéressants ce n'est pas tu n'es pas
représentative de la grande majorité de
nos concitoyens
très bref c'est vrai que je suis pas
technologue au sens strict mais je
connais bien la science des aliments
j'ai une formation en sciences des
aliments d'ingénieurs agroalimentaires
monsieur langage voulait revenir sur la
naturalité parce que je trouve que vous
avez soulever un point important
les sondages montrent que la société sur
le papier après dans les achats c'est
pas toujours ça correspond pas toujours
réponse au sondage mais qui a une vraie
recherche d'aliments plus naturel moins
transformée avec des listes
d'ingrédients plus courtes ça c'est ce
qui ressort quand même très fortement
des sondages
évidemment il s'agit pas de revenir à la
naturalité ce qu'on questionne c'est pas
la transformation donc il y a pas de
message anti-industriel au contraire on
pense que c'est plutôt le degré et en
fait
si vous voulez je pense même que Nova a
méritent qualitatif c'est d'avoir
justement trier le bon grain de livret
et avoir au sein des aliments
industriels dit bah au sein des aliments
industriels il y en a qui sont de
qualité donc nous avec cigare on a
calculé que c'est 28 30% qui se nomme
ultra transformé et il y a une certaine
dérive avec les tracking alimentaire et
le fractionnement on a été trop loin
donc au contraire je trouve que même
c'est peut-être paradoxal vous avez le
droit de pas être d'accord évidemment et
je pense que justement ça le mérite de
trier dans les aliments industriels ceux
qui sont de qualité qui peuvent être en
accord avec des systèmes alimentaires
durables et une certaine dérive où on a
été trop loin au point des fois de
vendre de la chimie comestible
c'est-à-dire qu'on a même plus des
aliments on recrée des aliments comme
les substituts de steak végétaux qui
convient même plus de vrais ingrédients
ce n'est qu'une recombinaison de
marqueurs ultra transformation
est-ce que c'est ça qu'on a envie à long
terme
très bien merci à vous pour ces débats
qui continueront de passionner
on va pouvoir poursuivre sur le deuxième
point
merci merci beaucoup à tous nos
intervenants c'était très riche et
matière à réflexion nous allons
maintenant passer à la seconde table
ronde consacrée aux conséquences de
l'industrialisation de l'alimentation
sur les habitudes et les comportements
alimentaires nous recevons dans ce cadre
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Poullain professeur
de sociologie à l'université Toulouse
Jean Jaurès madame Sophie Nicklaus
directrice de recherche à l'inrae
responsable de l'équipe déterminant du
comportement alimentaire au cours de la
vie relation avec la santé et Monsieur
Thierry Marx il s'est présent chef
cuisinier monsieur poulain je vous
laisse la parole pour votre propos
liminaire d'une dizaine de minutes merci
je vais donc rapidement me présenter je
suis professeur de sociologie quand vous
venez de dire à l'Université de Toulouse
membre d'une équipe emrcnrs et dans un
pôle qui s'appelle santal santé
alimentation et titulaire d'une chaire
monter conjointement par l'Université de
Toulouse et l'Université de Kuala Lumpur
qui s'appelle food studies food culture
également dans la partie dans la section
Sciences Sociales et humaine de
l'Académie d'Agriculture et j'ai une
double culture une culture technologique
j'ai fait de l'ingénierie des systèmes
alimentaires et ensuite j'ai mal tourné
je suis devenu sociologue de
l'alimentation donc je mobiliserai ici
dans ma présentation c'est de
compétences permettez-moi de démarrer
par ma conclusion pour gagner du temps
et ma conclusion elle est la suivante
dans le contexte contemporain de
l'avancée de la recherche il faut
soutenir cette recherche et il faut
financer des travaux pour faire avancer
et clarifier la problématique de la
classification
la question des matrices la la question
des liens entre alimentation et santé
parce que derrière la consommation de
ces produits alimentaires il peut y
avoir des facteurs confondants comme la
position sociale comme les revenus et
en faire le tri est important c'est le
premier élément le deuxième élément
c'est inviter les industriels à une
autocritique sur un certain nombre de
technologies qui sont appliquées et à
faire de la recherche et à faire faire
de la recherche le troisième point c'est
de d'aider à court terme les populations
qui sont victimes d'une situation
contemporaine nous avons nous avions
avant l'épidémie 9 millions,3 personnes
qui avaient qui étaient en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté avec des tensions sur
le budget alimentaire
en 2021 un million de plus est passé
sous le seuil de pauvreté et ce qui se
prépare et quelque chose de dramatique
et la question ici va se poser à court
terme donc pas peut-être de les prévenir
de quoi que ce soit et de leur donner
les moyennes manger et de réfléchir à
ces conditions et d'éviter ce qu'on
appelle le victime Lamine c'est de dire
vous êtes pauvre et en plus souvent j'ai
mal et vous allez tomber malade alors je
vais maintenant
argumenter ces différents points le
premier point consiste
à
souligner l'intérêt qu'il y a à analyser
les effets de l'industrialisation de
l'alimentation et un intervenant tout à
l'heure invité peut-être à l'élargir à
l'agriculture sur
la santé et les comportements des
populations
ceci dit on a un changement de
paradigme le premier article qui a
soutenu et promu l'idée de produits
ultra transformés s'intitulait le
problème n'est pas la nourriture ni les
nutriments mais plutôt la transformation
on a ici un changement de paradigme qui
est intéressant et qui essaye de relier
un degré de transformation avec des
conséquences sur la santé avec des
variables intermédiaires qui seraient
trop de sel trop de ceci trop de cela
c'est à dire des variables
comportementales
la difficulté qu'on vient de voir c'est
celle de définir la catégorie alors
comment travaillons-nous actuellement il
y a une thèse développée par une
ancienne ingénieur agronome qui est
sociologue et fait d'un trail de
sociologie des sciences on a recensé
plus de 124 publications sur ces
questions des publications qui vont dans
le sens positif des publications qui
calment un peu le jeu et qui
sont plus critiques
alors qu'est-ce qu'on constate on
constate que la définition elle bouge
elle démarre à 3 puis elle passe à 4
puis il y a des propositions à 5 ou 6
aujourd'hui et en fin de compte on a une
tension entre une approche analytique
qui va décomposer les sous-ensembles de
la transformation ou de l'ultra
transformation et puis de l'autre côté
une approche plus synthétique holistique
nous attendit qui travaille sur des
matrices ou travail sur des ensembles et
entre ces deux grilles de lecture et
bien on a un certain nombre de débats et
la question c'est pas de tomber dans le
discours religieux mais d'inviter les
chercheurs à avancer leur donner des
moyens pour avancer le plus vite
possible et pour clarifier cette
situation de l'autre côté la variable
dépendante c'est une variable à nouveau
énorme c'est la santé alors c'est
l'obésité c'est le diabète c'est les
maladies
la dernière ces types de maladies ou ces
types de on a des variables
confondantes qui sont la position
sociale qui sont le niveau d'éducation
et qui peuvent donner aux statut des
aliments ultra transformés un statut non
pas de causes mais un statut de marqueur
d'un autre d'une autre variable active
alors mes collègues médiologiques
n'ignorent pas ces questions il faut
leur donner les moyens de travailler et
d'avancer sur cette question là deuxième
point
c'est la question de
la situation sociale la situation
contemporaine au niveau de
l'alimentation
alors
si on avance
et si on a des connaissances qui
permettent de pointer du doigt de
réduire d'inviter collectivement les
gens de la filière alimentaire à réduire
des formes d'alimentation qui seraient
problématiques et bien c'est quelque
chose qui pourra marcher sans que les
consommateurs n'y pensent même et mais
il y a un deuxième levier et qui a été
présent depuis ce matin qui est
d'inviter les consommateurs à s'orienter
à faire les bons choix en leur indiquant
ce qu'il faut faire et ce qui est ce qui
est bon ce qui est pas bon et on a vu
des acteurs qui sont un peu
enthousiastes qui disent bah il faut y
aller et on nutriscors on a vu des
acteurs qui disent calmant que le jeu et
on a vu des politiques qui nous disent
et bien on peut pas rester larme au pied
s'il y a un vrai problème c'est pas dans
10 ans qu'il faut agir
alors regardons la situation
contemporaine la question de
du poids de la santé chez le
consommateur elle a du sens fort dans
les classes moyennes c'est à dire chez
les gens qui ont un peu de moyenne et
qui peuvent résonner à long terme quand
il s'agit de remplir le l'assiette
aujourd'hui et bien la question elle est
moins forte je dis pas qu'elle est
absente mais elle est moins forte et
donc je reviens sur ces chiffres qui
devraient nous alerter
on a un nombre important on a vu pendant
l'épidémie comment les associations qui
soutenaient l'aide alimentaire et restos
du cœur le Secours Catholique Secours
populaire ont été les banques
alimentaires ont été débordés par la
situation
la situation va s'aggraver
par les effets sur les prix et par des
effets conjoncturels
je pense qu'il est notre devoir
politique de réfléchir aux conditions
d'aide pour permettre
aux personnes qui vont souffrir et qui
en souffrent déjà de passer le cap et
cette question elle est liée
en termes de temporalité laissons le
temps de la recherche avancée
intervenant rapidement sur cette
question qui n'est pas que la question
des aliments transformés mais qui est
aussi la question de pouvoir avoir les
moyens de manger correctement parce
qu'il y a des choix qui sont pas des
choix complètement construits qui sont
des choix de contraintes je vous
remercie de votre attention
à vous bonjour vous m'entendez
oui très bien
donc mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues je vous remercie pour
l'invitation qui m'a été faite pour
participer à cette audition moi je vais
me focaliser sur la question suivante
quels sont les conséquences de
l'industrialisation de l'alimentation
sur les préférences et les comportements
élémentaires des enfants qui avaient été
soulevés précédemment j'ai un tout petit
peu élargir le périmètre par rapport à
celui de l'ultra transformation donc
pour y répondre je dois faire un petit
détour pour décrire d'où viennent les
préférences et les comportements
alimentaires le nourrisson équipé d'un
certain nombre de compétences qui vont
lui permettre de déguster différents
aliments après une période
d'apprentissage dès la naissance il peut
sentir les arômes et différencier les
saveurs il a des capacités de succion et
dégustations qui lui permettent de téter
ils devra développer des compétences qui
lui permettront plus tard de consommer
des aliments autre que le lait en
apprenant progressivement à les mâcher
et à les avaler
concernant ses préférences alimentaires
elles sont réduites à la plus simple
expression appréciation du goût sucré à
version pour le goût amer celui du café
par exemple éventuellement appréciation
des odeurs des aliments que la mer
consommait pendant la grossesse et
l'allaitement car certains arômes par
fume le liquide amniotique et le lait
maternel est peuvent être mémorisés et
perçus donc par le nourrisson dès le 3e
trimestre de grossesse il a été ainsi
démontré que l'exposition à de tels
arômes peut durablement influencer les
préférences alimentaires des enfants on
peut trouver des traces mémorielles même
chez l'adulte par exemple une étude
documente le fait que la vanille
parfumée certaines préparations
infantiles et
influence durablement le comportement de
l'adulte
ainsi on remarque déjà que
l'alimentation de la mer pendant la
grossesse c'est un facteur d'influence
des préférences de l'enfant et plus
largement des travaux conduits sur
l'origine développementale de la santé
et des maladies indique que le statut
nutritionnel de la mer mais aussi celui
du père sont susceptibles d'influencer
les paramètres croissance de l'enfant et
là parfois de programmer le
développement de l'obésité de celui-ci
donc tout ce qui a été dit précédemment
sur les conséquences sur la santé de la
consommation d'ultra transformé de
l'adulte à peuvent avoir aussi des
répercussions chez l'enfant à part cet
effet de programmation métabolique
concernant le domaine des préférences et
du comportement alimentaire donc tout
doit être appris par l'enfant de manière
postnatale sous la guidance de ses
parents car l'enfant ne n’est pas
autonome en la matière donc tous les
éléments qui permettent de décrire les
comportements alimentaires par exemple
ce que l'on mange à quel moment avec qui
est dans quelle quantité seront appris
progressivement par expérience
successives et imitation du comportement
des adultes responsables et par
observation de l'environnement
je voudrais revenir sur la période
d'allaitement en la matière
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
recommande pour tous les pays du monde
un allaitement exclusif jusqu'à l'âge de
6 mois âge à partir duquel l'enfant doit
commencer à manger d'autres aliments que
le lait alors que l'allaitement devrait
se prolonger jusqu'à deux ans et là en
France la réalité de l'allaitement est
très éloignée de ce que prône l'OMS
puisque seul 70% des mers initiales
allaitement à la naissance et à six mois
elles ne sont que 3% à allaiter
exclusivement leur enfant selon
différentes sources par exemple les
études elfes et Épiphanes en France donc
3% la santé publique a encore beaucoup à
faire pour espérer combler ces 97%
manquants or que donne-t-on à manger aux
enfants en substitution du lait de leur
mère des préparations pour nourrissons
préparation de suite selon la
dénomination des directives européennes
regardons le rétiquaire d'un peu plus
près ces aliments présentent toutes les
caractéristiques des aliments ultra
transformés le lait de vache n'est pas
adapté aux besoins nutritionnels du
nourrisson humain car bien trop riche en
protéines ainsi il est dégraissé coupé
enrichi en différentes huiles pour
approcher au mieux la composition du
lait humain l'étiquette fait ainsi
apparaître lactose huile végétale
tournesol coprac colza les crémé
lactosérum déminéralisée concentrez
lactosérum mais cycine de soja j'abrège
sans ignorer de nombreux minéraux et
vitamines
dont tout ceci auprès d'un grand nombre
d'opérations de transformation qui n'ont
rien à envier aux aliments évoqués
précédemment donc cracking du lait ajout
de matière grasse et Daddy d'additif
direct séchage pulvérisation pour
produire la poudre donc et la forme la
plus économique à transporter
que penser à ces produits répondent à
une réglementation stricte et qu'on
vienne aux besoins nutritionnels des
nourrissons qui sont très spécifiques
mais il s'agit d'un Oba 4 dans toute sa
splendeur pour reprendre la
classification évoquée précédemment
donc si l'on souhaite agir relativement
au sujet de la transformation ou l'ultra
transformation des aliments il faut être
prêt également à relever ce défi immense
que de promouvoir l'allaitement en
France qui devrait être le sujet de
préoccupation majeure compte tenu de la
fragilité du nourrisson cependant le
marché des préparations pour nourrisson
peser 1,4 milliards d'euros en 2021 en
40% sont consommés en France par nos
petits chérubins soit près de 90 000
tonnes donc en englobant les autres
produits destinés à l'alimentation
infantile on estime à 200 kg par bébé et
par an le marché de cette industrie
toutes ces préparations infantiles et
autres aliments industriels trouvent
leur origine dans une découverte majeure
qui a marqué l'histoire mondiale de
l'alimentation celle des germes par
Pasteur qui a construit à la mention qui
a conduit pardon à l'invention de la
pasteurisation et qui a donné lieu à de
nombreux autres innovations donc là en
poudre boîte de conserve etc ainsi
l'histoire de l'alimentation n'est pas
récente à les aliments préparer
industriellement connus une croissance
fulgurante à l’air industrielle comme
nous le décrit l'historien Martin
Bruegel ceci accompagné le tournant du
développement du travail des femmes
devenu de plus en plus répandue dans les
usines qui maillaient le territoire
français donc cette libération du
travail alimentaire maternel et féminin
pour l'enfant mais aussi pour le reste
de la famille a connu son essor grâce à
l'industrialisation de l'alimentation ce
qui a permis à la femme de s'éloigner
des fourneaux
on va revenir maintenant au 21e siècle
au développement des préférences
alimentaires des enfants donc nous avons
développé dans mon équipe une manière de
conceptualiser le plaisir alimentaire en
trois dimensions qui se complètent
mutuellement premièrement le plaisir
sensoriel directement lié aux propriétés
organoleptiques des aliments grâce à les
sucrées craquants croustillant etc ainsi
qu'à leur densité énergétique
c'est-à-dire la quantité de calories
apportées pour 100 g on s'est en effet
qu'avec l'apprentissage un aliment
devient d'autant plus apprécié qu'il est
riche en calories
deuxièmement le plaisir Commençal c'est
à dire le plaisir que l'on ressent
lorsque l'on partage avec d'autres le
poulet du dimanche n'est-il pas d'autant
plus savoureux qu'il est partagé avec la
famille ou les amis
troisièmement le plaisir cognitif
c'est-à-dire le plaisir ressenti en lien
avec certaines caractéristiques du
produit qui ne sont pas directement
liées à sa composition nutritionnelle
comme les idées qu'on peut s'en faire
les valeurs toutes les dimensions liées
à l'imaginaire
comment ces dimensions se
construisent-elles et sous l'effet des
expériences alimentaires encore et
toujours donc l'enfant va apprendre ses
dimensions du plaisir alimentaire donc
plaisir sensoriel comment ça les
cognitif en lien avec ces expériences
alimentaires et en quoi le concept
d'aliments ultra transformé vient-il
télescoper ces trois dimensions du
plaisir alimentaire du point de vue
sensoriel les aliments ultra transformés
sont produits par des entreprises qui
s'assurent à minima que leur produit
soit appréciés des consommateurs voir
consacre des avertises des
investissements significatifs afin de
s'assurer que leurs produits au plus
près possible
au point de féliciter c'est à dire un
point de satisfaction maximale au cours
duquel toute modification de la
formulation ne peut que conduire à une
réduction de son appréciation
comme ça a été dit le rôle de nombreux
additifs entrant dans la composition des
aliments ultra transformés consiste à
renforcer ses propriétés organoleptiques
colorants et multipliant agent de
texture arômes etc donc difficile dans
ces conditions pour des produits plus
bruts d'être compétitifs pour espérer
concurrencer ce point de félicité
optimale
de plus les aliments ultra transformés
présentent souvent une forte densité
énergétique et des propriétés de texture
qui en font des aliments faciles à
consommer ces facteurs sont notoirement
associés à une consommation plus rapide
qui facilite un risque de consommation
encore maximiser par une forte densité
énergétique
enfin les aliments industriels sont très
standardisés dans leur process ce qui
limite fortement les variations
organoleptiques et habituent les
consommateurs à attendre toujours le
même coup dans un produit donné alors
que la nature est plus généreuse en
subtile variation et en effet Monsieur
Longuet les pommes d'un même arbre n'ont
pas toutes le même goût
du point de vue de la commensalité ce
qui dépasse complètement la qualité
nutritionnelle seule des aliments ultral
transformés les emballages industriels
permettent de nouveaux usages des
aliments par exemple portionner un
aliment permet une consommation
individuelle pourquoi pas dans le cadre
d'un repas partagé le développement de
ces usages ne peut qu'isoler les
consommateurs des uns des autres ce qui
peut aussi être dérégulateurs car le
comportement alimentaire est sous
contrôle social limitation sociale est
un des moteurs des apprentissages mais
qui ne peut jouer pleinement son rôle
que si les convives consomment la même
chose ce point extrêmement documenté
dans la littérature sur la psychologie
du comportement n'est pas le temps de
tout détailler
ainsi l'individualisation des
consommations permise par les aliments
ultras transformés peut vite être
associé à une perte de commensalité à
une perte de culture culinaire et par
extension à une perte des compétences
culinaires
enfin du point de vue cognitif les
aliments ultra transformés sont associés
à des imaginaires publicitaires testés à
prouver par les consommateurs et c'est
ce blanc slogan ont vite fait de
s'imposer dans nos têtes donc
vous connaissez tous les slogans
associés à des marques alimentaires et
juste l'évocation d'un slogan par
exemple ne passons pas à côté des choses
simples peut vous suffire à imaginer la
marque donc les images les musiques
également peuvent faire souvenir surgir
en nous le nom d'aliments grâce aux
miracle de l'encodage mémorial qui
permet de fondre en nous souvenir
différentes composantes liées aux
émotions qui contribuent à faire désirer
un produit
ce qui pourrait naître camuson et se
demanderont beaucoup plus inquiétant que
cela une méta-analyse des données de la
littérature scientifique conduites
récemment montre que le marketing
alimentaire il y a une augmentation
significative à des quantités consommées
à une orientation différentielle des
choix et des préférences des enfants
envers des produits promus par la
publicité donc cette étude précise qu'il
reste difficile d'établir une
association avec la santé dentaire et le
statut pondérale des enfants amen
néanmoins l'interroge comment lutter en
matière de santé publique quand on sait
que les publicités à télévision sont en
majorité pour des aliments à faible
qualité nutritionnelles
qui sont aussi majoritaires dans l'offre
des produits à destinaux enfants comme
le disait monsieur farde tout à l'heure
et qu'elles sont plus souvent vues dans
des foyers des catégories
socio-professionnelles moins favorisées
ou le surpoids
donc l'émergence massive d'aliments
industriels ultra transformés ou non à
destination de la population enfantine
et le succès de ses offres permet de
montrer très clairement leur adéquation
à une demande entre guillemets c'est
bien l'art du marketing de créer cette
demande donc force est de constater que
de ce point de vue l'industrie
alimentaire a été très efficace donc on
voyait des chiffres tout à l'heure sur
la part d'aliment ultra transformé dans
l'alimentation des adultes une étude par
exemple pointe au Royaume-Uni plus de
65% des calories consommées par les
enfants proviennent d'aliments ultra
transformés
pour conclure mon propos je veux
simplement rappeler que le comportement
alimentaire comme tout comportement
dépend très largement de l'environnement
dans lequel il s'exerce même si nous
nous croyons libres notre comportement
est sous influence de nombreuses
influences parmi lesquelles la
disponibilité des aliments elle de loin
la plus déterminante les modes de vie
actuels étant ce qu'ils sont il est
illusoire de vouloir revenir à des temps
ou chacun était capable de se nourrir à
ma base d'un jardin potager justement
dans ce contexte il convient de porter
l'attention toute particulière à la
qualité des aliments qui sont dans notre
assiette pour garantir que dans le pays
qui se targue d'être celui de la
gastronomie la qualité ne soit pas
présente que dans l'assiette des grands
chefs et qu'elle puisse être la panache
de tous et toutes cette attention à la
qualité des produits peut se faire grâce
aux outils de profilage nutritionnel
classique au menu triscore grâce à
l'examen des additifs et de leur
sécurité et des procédés de
transformation et enfin en prêtant
également un regard critique sur la
publicité pourtant sur les produits
alimentaires
en résumé et convient de s'interroger
comment protéger les enfants de la
séduction immédiate que présente les
aliments ultra transformés comment faire
pour qu'ils gardent le goût d'aliments
plus brut non marcutés qu'ils auraient
plaisir à partager entre générations
l'éducation alimentaire patauge en
France pays qui l'a pourtant inventé
faute de moyens et plutôt que de vouloir
rééduquer il est sans doute plus
pertinent de prévenir en évitant une
surexposition des enfants à de tels
aliments je vous remercie pour votre
attention
merci beaucoup pour cette exposé nous
pas je passe la parole maintenant à
Monsieur Thierry ma non vous pouvez
parler à la place merci beaucoup
merci
je suis très embarrassé parce que tout a
été dit
moi je viens du monde de l'artisanat
donc du monde des produits transformés
pardon mais j'essaie de les transformer
dans meilleures conditions possibles
donc j'ai écouté religieusement tout ce
qui a été dit parce que c'était
passionnant mais c'était un peu de entre
nous entre soi et moi je me suis
intéressé il y a 20 ans
par rapport à mon métier aux produits
bruts d'abord et qu'est-ce que c'est
avec un bon produit son impact social
son impact environnemental et son impact
nutritionnel donc je travaillais avec
bleu avec bleu blanc coeur bien sûr mais
avec Pierre veille surtout et on
regardait ce qu'on pouvait faire déjà
pour expliquer ce que devait être un bon
produit qualité des sols qualité des
herbages bien-être animal et l'OMS
aujourd'hui nous dit que c'est la santé
globale c'est cela
une fois qu'on avait travaillé là-dessus
on avait défini ce qui était un bon
produit et bien on peut parler d'ultra
transformation effectivement quel
produit on transforme si déjà à la base
on additionne un simple de problématique
forcément que on aura dans un produit
ultra transformé des produits de
mauvaise qualité et nous les avons et
puis ce qui a pas été beaucoup évoqué
c'est cette théorie du low cost
dans les années 70 on a laissé entrevoir
cette théorie du low cost comme la
solution au pouvoir d'achat en gros vous
renoncez à la quality à la qualité et en
échange de quoi on vous on vous garantit
un petit prix et là ça a été le mariage
de la carpe et du lapin parce que
effectivement et bien aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans quelque chose de
terrifiant nous avions déjà la fracture
sociale aujourd'hui nous avons
l'alimentation à deux vitesses ceux qui
vont plutôt bien et qui peuvent entendre
tous les discours et tous les toutes les
analyses qui ont été faites et bien
mange plutôt pas trop mal dans des
circuits extrêmement courts avec une une
capacité à analyser ce qu'il mange et
pourquoi il se restaure et puis il y a
ceux comme ça a été évoqué par monsieur
le sénateur qui qui n'ont pas le choix
qui n'ont le que le choix du prix et là
cette terrifiant parce que là vous avez
le droit à l'ultras transformer et de
l'ultra internationalisé et ça pour moi
c'est la partie la plus choquante de
notre alimentation aujourd'hui parce
qu'effectivement dans toutes les
analyses que vous avez pu voir et bien
c'est un impact colossal sur la santé et
la santé publique avec le coût que cela
peut représenter et puis il y a des
choses qui n'ont pas été évoquées c'est
bien sûr l'alimentation bien sûr lutter
tout contre tous ces additifs il y a des
actifs qui ne servent à rien il y a des
actifs qui sont utiles dans
l'alimentation surtout quand vous
commencez on pourrait parler de
l'appertisation par exemple on a besoin
de quelques béquilles comme le caroubier
ou autre pour stériliser ou appertiser
quelques boîtes de conserve pour nos
marins mais là on est rentré dans un jeu
extrêmement compliqué de l'ultra ultra
transformation c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des plats qui
n'ont uniquement une valeur
nutritionnelle sans relation au goût et
ça c'est c'est dommageable là aussi pour
pour la génération à venir parce que
effectivement on s'éloigne beaucoup
beaucoup de ce qu'est la commercialité
et le partage de goût et des saveurs
alors je j'ai pas beaucoup de temps de
parole et ça me suffit largement pour
aller vers une conclusion ma conclusion
elle est simple il y a des produits qui
sont très mauvais très très mauvais pour
la santé publique et on les connaît ils
ont été identifiés sur toutes les
analyses que vous avez pu voir le
sursuré le surgras le sur transformer le
soda on a évoqué le soda que et les
phosphates du soda on connaît les dégâts
dans dans chez nos concitoyens donc
aujourd'hui ces produits doivent être
taxés et ça c'est on l'a fait pour le
tabac il faut accepter de le faire pour
les produits qui ne sont pas acceptables
dans notre alimentation pourquoi parce
que là aussi ça a été largement évoqué
si nous voulons arrêter de consommer une
mauvaise alimentation il faut refaire
des mangeurs et le mangeur de demain il
se construit dans un lieu de
responsabilisation qui à l'école ou des
lieux d'autres lieux de
responsabilisation il faut réapprendre à
manger au plus jeune pour que demain
c'est mangeurs ne soient pleurs plus des
surconsommateurs et face la différence
entre un bon produit et un mauvais
produit pour protéger un le vivre
ensemble de le fait que cette société
soit beaucoup moins malade et puis trois
avec ses financements sur l'alimentation
financée aussi la lutte contre la
sédentarité parce que bien souvent dans
certains de nos quartiers nous nous
travaillons nous avons 10 écoles dans
les quartiers d'inclusion et d'insertion
et on s'aperçoit que la sédentarité le
manque de sommeil a une forte un fort
impact sur l'alimentation donc voilà je
vais conclure comme je viens de le dire
mais je me battrai tout ce qui est
possible pour moi sur cette formation
culinaire pour nos plus jeunes pour que
ce soit des mangeurs et plus des
consommateurs et puis le faire avec
toute la force parce que il y va aussi
de notre agriculture pour modifier
l'agriculture il faut modifier son mode
de consommation voilà merci de votre
attention
merci
je partage tout à fait ce qui vient
d'être puisque j'avais j'ai fait
inscrire quand on a eu la loi école de
confiance parce que je reviens sur
l'éducation
le fait que dans à l'éducation nationale
on favorise les travaux manuels et
j'entendais par travaux manuels qu'on
réintroduise qu'on avait par le passé
notamment les cours de cuisine en
collège et pas que les cours de cuisine
tous les cours de travaux manuels qui
manquent énormément la formation de nos
jeunes oui je vous laisse merci
parce que il faut avec le ministère
concerné défendre l'idée du cours de
cuisine qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un cours
de cuisine un cours de cuisine vous avez
un cours d'arithmétique vous avez un
cours de français vous avez un cours
d'histoire-géographie et vous avez un
cours d'éducation civique ce qui est
extrêmement important de nos jours et ça
dès le plus jeune âge et effectivement
en taxant les produits qui sont pas bons
pour la santé de nos enfants je pense
aux soda et bien nous trouverons les
financements nécessaires pour animer ses
cours avec le personnel éducatif mais
aussi avec les professionnels de la
filière et je pardon j'ai loupé un point
cette industrialisation de notre
alimentation passe aussi par l'artisanat
aujourd'hui l'artisanat est touché par
cette industrialisation les produits
ultra transformés sont entrés depuis 20
ans et plus de 20 ans dans nos cuisines
dites gastronomiques là aussi il faut
des indications ça a été évoqué sur les
emballages je rappelle que la cuisine
dite basse température vient de
l'univers du monde industriel et que
dans certains professionnels nous
cuisons basse température avec des
matières plastiques doux nous
connaissons aujourd'hui l'interaction
entre le produit transformé donc il faut
que quand même un artisan prenne ses
responsabilités quand il utilise ce type
de méthode il faut qu'il le marque sur
sa carte de restaurant
merci je partage tout à fait donc je
rappelle également que le quand même le
repas gastronomique des Français est
inscrit au patrimoine immatériel de
l'humanité à l'Unesco et que nous avons
effectivement des valeurs à défendre sur
ce sujet là alors moi je reviendrai très
rapidement sur peut-être si un des
intervenants peut reprendre sur
notamment sur la grande pauvreté que
nous avons dans notre pays qui ne fait
que qu'augmenter et sur l'accès à une
alimentation sur et durable et saine
bien évidemment et sur les peut-être des
chiffres sur les consommations par les
nos populations les plus défavorisées
et si vous pensez que vous l'avez un
petit peu dit mais on va le redire si
les égalités sont dus à un déficit
d'information ou tout simplement comme
vous l'avez dit enfin je sais pas faire
la part des choses entre le fait qu'on
vous intéresse pas parce qu'on a juste
porte-monnaie en fait en vue ou le fait
qu'on pourrait
en quelque sorte
éduquée enfin le mot éduquer me plaît
pas trop mais éduqué un peu la
population sur cette notion de d'ultra
transformation et de leur parce que
franchement moi-même je découvre des
choses quand même en faisant ce sujet là
je m'en doutais un petit peu mais voilà
je pense que la majeure partie de la
population majesticide beaucoup
là-dessus ne sait pas ne sait pas ne
regarde pas parce que c'est écrit en
tout petit et achète des produits en
pensant que que c'est naturel que c'est
bon sans se douter que derrière et
notamment au niveau des sodas évidemment
c'est très important
et après une j'ai une autre question sur
le l'aspect l'attractivité gustative sur
ces exhausseurs de goût sur le est-ce
qu'il y a création d'un effet addictif
vraiment est-ce que la hausse de
consommation de ces produits ult
transformer se traduit par des concerts
des conséquences observables directement
sur les préférences gustatives dans la
population et est-ce qu'on assiste
quelque part parce que c'est très récent
tout ça à une uniformisation des
préférences voilà je sais des questions
que je lance comme ça ce voilà
sur le cette normalisation au niveau des
goûts d'abord la cuisine c'est donner de
la mémoire à de l'éphémère donc il y a
cette notion là nous qu'on défend dans
dans l'univers de la gastronomie mais
bien évidemment tous ces produits ultra
transformés quand vous prenez la vanille
par exemple la vanille dans un yaourt et
que vous faites goûter et je travaille
de temps en temps pour pour l'industrie
et bien je vois bien que les tests pour
les gens qui achètent nos gâteaux disent
ah non mais je préférais l'autre avant
l'autre avant c'était un arôme de
synthèse donc le vrai arôme de la
vanille n'est pas le n'est pas mis
dedans donc c'est vrai que ça crée je
n'ai pas de compétences sur l'addiction
mais en tout cas ça crée une
attractivité différente et on se
souvient de finalement du mauvais goût
de la vanille et pas du véritable goût
de la vanille et c'est cette
attractivité là qui est souvent gênante
mais encore une fois je reviens sur la
formation La formation olfactive des
plus jeunes pour construire leur
connaissance au goût aux saveurs et de
se protéger et de protéger leur santé
justement moi je vois sur ce sujet là
quelque chose dont on doit se préoccuper
on a maintenant des générations
d'enfants qui n'ont pas connu leur
parent en train de faire la cuisine les
tout jeune qu'on a maintenant sans doute
alors qu'elle part de la population cela
représente-t-il parce que dans ma
génération sans doute qu'on avait tous
nos maires et nos pères aussi qui
faisaient la cuisine dont on avait
l'expérience en fait qui manque
peut-être aux jeunes générations c'est
un peu une question que je me pose là
dans l'idée de ces cours d'éducation
j'ai parlé d'éducation civique et ça a
été évoqué dans dans beaucoup d'analyses
la commercialité pourquoi je mangerais
avec les autres alors qu'on a
individualisé aussi le fait de manger
quand il y a plus le lien social dans
l'alimentation tout devient extrêmement
compliqué ce rassembler pour manger
reprend du sens et c'est là où le cours
peut donner cette envie de partager de
la connaissance des saveurs et un
certain nombre de choses qui peuvent
être bonnes pour cette alimentation
encore une fois je travaille sur une
petite planète qui est la gastronomie
mais le combat politique qui est amené
sur l'alimentation est un combat
extrêmement fort et je pense que ici
tout le monde en est conscient
je peux peut-être compléter sur
la question d'une uniformisation des
préférences alimentaires enfin ce qui
est certain c'est que le facteur numéro
1 de la prestation d'un aliment c'est
son degré de familiarité pour le
consommateur alors c'est
particulièrement vrai chez les enfants
notamment dans la phase qu'on appelle de
néophobie alimentaire c'est-à-dire en
gros entre deux et 7 ans ou c'est
vraiment le facteur numéro 1 de
l'appréciation mais on le retrouve
également chez les adultes sur
l'uniformisation des préférences il y a
une multitude de marques toutes n'ont
pas exactement les mêmes profils ou
caractéristiques sensorielles mais
néanmoins on voit bien que a préféré la
préférence s'oriente tout le temps vers
des goûts qui sont extrêmement
travaillés alors si j'étais économiste
que je ne suis pas j'étudie le
comportement j'aurais envie de dire il
n'y a qu'à observer l'expansion du
marché des produits industriels pour
comprendre leur succès et comprendre
dans quelle mesure ça modeler les
préférences des consommateurs
sur l'addiction moi je n'aime pas
tellement le terme addiction alimentaire
parce que l'alimentation est un besoin
incompressible qu'on l'a rappelé Anthony
fardey tout à l'heure on doit manger
plusieurs fois par jour pour subvenir à
nos besoins nutritionnels et de manière
qualitative de préférence donc parler
d'une taniction pour un comportement
indispensable je suis extrêmement gêné
ce que les neuroscientifiques nous
disent quand on regarde toutes les
études et j'ai fait plusieurs fois des
analyses de la littérature sur ce cette
question là c'est on peut dire
il y a une addiction comportementale à
consommer évidemment puisqu'elle est
indispensable l'addiction à telle ou
telle produit c'est difficile de le
caractériser véritablement sauf dans des
cas extrêmement
spécifiques par exemple des
consommations de soda une litre par jour
enfin voilà on a vraiment des choses
extrêmement spécifiques
sur les inégalités sociales je voulais
peut-être passer le relais à Jean-Pierre
Poulain peut-être qu'il pourra compléter
merci Sophie ce qui s'est passé dans les
années qui viennent de s'écouler alors
même que pendant longtemps on a eu
encore du pouvoir d'achat qui est
progressé
le vécu d'un certain nombre de groupes
c'était que les choses devaient te
venaient de plus en plus difficile en
réalité pour comprendre ça et il faut
introduire la notion de reste à vivre
dans un budget de ménage c'est-à-dire
dans un budget global de ménage il y a
un certain nombre de dépenses qui sont
prédéfinies comme le loyer comme les
abonnements et la partie sur laquelle on
peut faire porter des décisions c'est ce
qu'on appelle le reste à vivre et dans
les années qui sont écoulées
un certain nombre de choses se sont en
transformer des modalités de leur
commercialisation par exemple lorsque
j'étais abonné au téléphone il y a une
trentaine d'années et bien je payais un
abonnement pas très cher et puis je
payais des communications et puis si
j'avais des difficultés
financière mais je téléphonais moyen ou
pas du tout aujourd'hui on est dans des
situations qui sont différentes on va
avoir un abonnement et quand on dépasse
on peut avoir des coûts qui augmentent
encore donc la partie qui prédéfinie a
augmenté et donc le reste à vivre
diminue et ça donne cette ambiguïté ou
cette apparente contradiction
et dans le reste à vivre et bien il y a
l'alimentation et durant la période de
crise qu'on a vécu les plus pauvres se
sont retrouvés dans une situation de de
double punissement de double il se
retrouvait à devoir manger à la maison
acheter de la nourriture et d'une
certaine façon il ne bénéficiait plus
d'une série d'aides qu'il aurait été
offert à travers les dispositifs de
soutien de la cantine de l'entreprise de
la cantine des écoles etc et on a vu ici
un facteur d'accroissement des
inégalités
importants qui a touché en grande partie
la question de l'alimentation
voilà je voulais juste souligner le fait
que ces mêmes personnes et bien on va
avoir des taux d'obésité qui sont plus
importants que dans les autres parties
de la société c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir toute une série de facteurs qui
sont liés aux
biens entre pathologies et position
sociale et à la question que vous posiez
sur l'intérêt qui peut y avoir
d'ailleurs lorsque vous avez des
difficultés à raisonner
et à faire votre budget sur le moins la
question de l'influence de la santé
de ce que vous faites sur la santé dans
10 15 20 ans on l'ignore pas bien
évidemment mais c'est quelque chose qui
passe au second plan et qui est très
prégnant qui a du sens lorsque vous êtes
dans des positions un peu plus
confortable voilà donc c'est tout le
débat toute la difficulté qu'on a avec
l'épidémiologie et la santé publique
c'est-à-dire que la difficulté c'est
d'éviter
déjà en moyennement riches parlent des
gens moyennes-marie et comment on va
faire passer les messages auprès de gens
qui sont liés à des situations sociales
avec des contraintes lourdes alors
excusez-moi d'avoir mis un peu
d'émotions tout à l'heure je vais un peu
d'émotions parce que nous sommes au
début de quelque chose qui va être
problématique
et je pense qu'il faut qu'on y
réfléchisse et c'est pas l'un ou l'autre
bien évidemment il faut continuer la
réflexion il faut la faire avancer mais
là il y a quelque chose qui se joue qui
se prépare sur laquelle il me semble que
nous avons une responsabilité de
citoyens et qu'on a une responsabilité
politique
je voudrais compléter sur la question du
plaisir cognitif que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure enfin des imaginaires on a des
imaginaires différents dans les
différentes classes sociales et
notamment pour les cas les classes
sociales les moins favorisées l'achat
alimentaire est parfois le seul achat
possible
parmi les biens de consommation parce
que le prix unitaire est faible donc on
peut acheter une bouteille de soda à 2
euros ou un euro ça reste accessible et
dans ce cas là on préfère les marques
parce que les marques sont associées à
une certaine valeur on a l'impression de
pouvoir faire plaisir à son enfant en
achetant une marque
sur une bouteille de soda ce qui est
plus compliqué pour une paire de baskets
un jean ou un téléphone
donc dans ce point de vue là le rôle de
la publicité il est majeur également je
me suis permis d'insister là dessus ça
dépasse vraiment largement le sujet du
jour mais je pense qu'on peut pas parler
de l'alimentation transformée
à vos questions qui est majeurs et ça ce
problème de distorsion de concurrence
que cela introduit par rapport aux
produits plus brut c'est un problème
majeur aussi comment voulez-vous qu'un
enfant s'intéresse à une pomme
qui n'a aucun marketing alors que on lui
vend des gourdes de produits super
agréable super travaillé pour être les
plus
les plus appréciées possible on peut pas
demander cet effort à un enfant c'est
impossible on peut pas le demander non
plus à un adulte et donc il est vraiment
important de repenser les choses
globalement sans mettre de côté ce point
je peux dire un mot oui oui allez-y bien
sûr
ce qui est bien aussi souligné par
Carlos Monteiro donc qui a créé la
classification Nova c'est que ces
aliments du groupe 4 temps justement à
se substituer auprès des plus jeunes aux
aliments du groupe 3 qui sont on va dire
transformés normalement les plats
traditionnels les plaques des terroirs
etc ou la cuisine à la maison et on a
des aliments qui imitent ces aliments
qui les remplacent et qui créent une
hyper standardisation des goûts facile
d'accès peut exigeant et qui éloignent
les plus jeunes des goûts plus subtiles
des vrais aliments monsieur Marx par
l'aide à vanille par exemple c'est un
très bon exemple et par exemple si un
yaourt a juste un arôme certes cet arôme
n'est peut-être pas nocif pour la santé
mais qu'est-ce qu'on veut est-ce qu'on
veut habiter nos enfants à des arômes ou
à des vrais fruits donc on voit que le
pain de mie aux États-Unis a remplacé le
vrai pain les céréales petit déjeuner
pour enfants en France qui sont
majoritairement ultra transformés ont
remplacer le vrai pain
les formules infantiles ont remplacé le
lait maternel le soda remplacer l'eau et
on peut faire la liste est très longue
donc il y a un vrai danger quand même
auprès des plus jeunes de les éloigner
et c'est très bien d'observer dans les
pays émergents notamment et dans les
élus pacifique ou même dans des régimes
traditionnels protecteurs comme
méditerranéens ou Okinawa qui commence à
être pénétré par ultra transformation et
qui éloigne donc nos enfants des vrais
animaux
oui justement j'étais dans ma vie
antérieure professeure de
physique-chimie et en troisième je on
faisais la synthèse de l'arôme de banane
celui qui est dans les fameux bonbons
donc c'était déjà intéressant pour que
les élèves se rendent compte que voilà
c'était une réaction chimique à partir
de produits mettaient des lunettes et
des gants quand même pour manipuler un
peu dangereux et qu'après c'était très
éloigné évidemment de du goût de la
vraie banane qui vient et ça c'est le
prof de chimie qui parle d'une centaine
de molécules différentes qui interfèrent
pour donner ce goût subtil le goût de la
fraise c'est encore plus plus important
au niveau du nombre de molécules qui qui
agissent ensemble enfin qui qui sont qui
donnent ce goût subtil et je faisais
toujours réagir mes élèves par rapport à
ça
et notamment sur la vanille bien
évidemment parce que la vanille c'est le
même sujet c'est même la vanille qui est
vendue n'a même pas une molécule qui
existe dans la vraie vanille et donc
fabriquer indus également et pour
attirer leur attention sur la
dénomination saveur vanille il y en a
pas
bien évidemment et pour pour faire en
sorte que il soit plus apte à faire des
choix dans le futur
voilà de après bon c'était une petite
intervention pour leur montrer ces
choses-là quoi pour qu'ils soient un
petit peu attentif et puis qui ne
l'oublie pas effectivement le vrai goût
des choses du fruit lui-même par exemple
c'est à dire qu'on réduit un arôme qui
est complexe et qui composait de
plusieurs dizaines de molécules une
molécule c'est ce qu'on appelle le
réductionnisme on simplifie un système
complexe alors c'est très rentable mais
à long terme ça peut nous donner dans
des impasses je pense que ça rejoint
aussi le point soulevé par Monsieur Marx
qui est très important
de lier les aliments à l'origine de leur
production
c'est on voit que c'est quelque chose
c'est une menace également
tous ces imaginaires publicitaires en
fait ne font que déconnecter
l'alimentation et une partie de la
qualité elle est construite aussi
évidemment
aux champs comme il a bien expliqué donc
si on veut éclairer les futurs ou les
générations présentes aux enjeux de la
qualité des aliments il faut
impérativement pouvoir se donner les
moyens d'expliquer ce lien d'expliquer
d'où viennent les aliments comment elle
comment ils sont produits
sinon je pense que tout le reste du
discours qu'on pourra avoir sera
complètement déconnecté de la réalité
je voulais revenir juste
je vraiment je vais dans le sens de tout
ce qui est dit mais j'aurais revenir
juste sur le nutrition voilà un outil
qui au départ me paraissait extrêmement
formidable quand on s'intéresse à
l'alimentation et finalement très opaque
pour le simplicitoyen c'est-à-dire que
je viens de regarder comme ça avant de
venir ce matin
nutri-score B sur des nuggets donc vous
ne connaissez pas du tout le sourcing du
produit et nous triscore a sur du
roquefort ou sur 100 g d'huile d'olive
vous voyez que c'est compliqué de pas
ramener les choses à la portion aussi
parce que sur 100 g de nuggets c'est 100
g de olive qui va boire 100 g d'huile
d'olive ou qui va manger 100 g de
roquefort à la fois et c'est aussi
l'aide qu'on peut donner à porter aux
consommateurs avec des nutriscors qui
soient vraiment d'être d'une efficacité
redoutable vous savez quand on comparait
à kilo de sucre et une bouteille de soda
ça ça parle aux mamans et au papa qui
achètent en disant la tête que j'exagère
et s'il ramenait ce nutriscore pour
l'adapter à des publics qui des fois
n'ont pas l'analyse et on peut le
comprendre de valoriser et je termine
mon propos où on a beaucoup
parlé des gens qui sont à l'aide
alimentaire et notamment je parlais il y
a très peu de temps avec le président
des Restos du Coeur où on s'interrogeait
sur comment mieux aider ces personnes
qui étaient en grande difficulté
alimentaire on leur fournissant des
produits qui soient corrects pour leur
santé future ça aussi c'est une vraie
interrogation dans notre politique
alimentaire en France
oui juste pour rebondir l'escar de
composition sont réductionnistes elles
sont quand même basées sur une idée un
petit peu discutable du potentiel santé
d'un aliment donc il rentre pas compte
de la qualité globale d'un aliment c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont en fait du mal à
classer les aliments dans la réalité
c'est à dire c'est des constructions
intellectuelles que quand on applique
dans la réalité comme il y a les fait
matrice qui est pas prise en compte
forcément ça donne des aberrations et on
peut rappeler quand même que 57% des
produits industriels nutrition AB sont
ultra transformés donc il y a un risque
que ces scores de composition qui sont
priorisés dans le monde entier en fait
soutiennent ultra-transformation et
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on voit c'est à
dire que la chimie comestible qui
n'avait pas de label maintenant un label
une histoire AB donc ça c'est les
dérives du réductionnisme
juste là dessus sur une crise score une
je conçois bien que l'ultra
transformation soit très très importante
etc mais quand même la composition
nutritionnelle du produit ça reste
quelque chose de je pense aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui incontournable et je pense
que toute la on a parlé de de du lien
entre les aliments transformés la santé
en disant pour moi ça n'était que des
associations même si elles sont très
suggestives etc sur ce qui est le sel
par exemple on a des données qui sont
absolument
non non discutable donc je pense que le
discours sur la transmission il est
important mais il doit pas masquer le
discours sur le discours sur la
nutrition et même si le nutrise corps
n'est pas parfait il a quand même je
pense beaucoup de
véhiculent quand même beaucoup
d'informations et une information qui
est je pense plus voilà plus solide
comme je l'ai comme je l'ai dit que que
la classification Nova et qui apporte
quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'informations faut pas jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain
on voit qu'effectivement encore un peu
de débat là et que un peu de recherche
est nécessaire pour créer un consensus
je voudrais revenir sur un point qui
était évoqué par Thierry Marx et la
distinction entre consommateurs et
mangeur oui par exemple
expérimentalement on peut mettre en
évidence que en utilisant une
nutri-score le caddie de ceux qui
achètent et à une meilleure qualité
nutritionnelle sauf que quand on achète
quelque chose on achète souvent pour un
groupe pour une famille et ensuite ça ça
va rentrer dans des placards on va faire
de la cuisine on va y accéder de façon
différenciée selon les individus on va
le manger de différentes façons et donc
il y a toute
certains événements qui vont avoir lieu
et qui renvoient au comportement
alimentaire qui renvoie à toutes ces
dimensions culinaires
aux convivial convivialité elle a
commencé à lutter au partage etc et donc
ce que la personne va véritablement
ingérer c'est quelque chose qui est
assez qui peut être éloigné parfois les
pas mais pour lequel on a un écart entre
ce qui est acheté et ce qui est consommé
et donc si éducation il y avait à faire
mais il faut qu'on se pose bien la
question de l'éducation c'est-à-dire que
s'il s'agit de transmettre peu de choses
on va assez vite trouver un consensus
mais si on veut transmettre pas mal de
choses la question se pose de la
connaissance des aliments de la
connaissance de leurs usages domestiques
de ce qui va être fait à la maison de la
façon dont on mange et cette façon dont
on mange elle est socialement
différenciée elle est culturellement
différenciée et de nouveau faut faire
attention à la façon dont on va
enseigner ça est-ce que j'enseigne comme
normal ce qui est ce que les classes
moyennes supérieures font
comment je prends en compte cette
diversité c'est pas insoluble mais je
veux dire que on a ici quand on milite
pour l'éducation alimentaire c'est
justement cette prise en charge en plus
de nutritionnel de ce qui transforme un
produit acheté en un produit qui est
dans une assiette et qui va être
consommé
sur un je revenir 2 secondes sur le
nutri-score c'est vrai que bien souvent
un produit est dégradé or que ça a pas
les mêmes implications mettre de la gare
à gare en finale dans un produit c'est
tout de suite dégradé mais au même titre
que les trans glutaminas ça a pas les
mêmes les mêmes incidences et puis ce
qui menave aujourd'hui aussi c'est de
retrouver des trans glutaminas dans
l'artisanat bon ça c'est pour les choses
et après pour l'initiation je parle pas
de cours académique de cuisine vraiment
c'est de préparer un manuel très précis
sur tout ce qu'on peut amener dans
l'initiation au goût aux saveurs et à la
découverte des produits au fur et à
mesure des années que l'élève va passer
en scolarité donc ça commence certes par
le geste les saveurs la pratique et de
faire vivre le groupe autour d'une idée
assez générale des sens liés à
l'alimentation pas simplement l'idée de
savoir ou ne pas savoir transformer les
produits et je suis certain que
va diffuser comme l'impact
environnemental à diffusé chez les
enfants très tôt chez les parents et
c'est ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est
aujourd'hui que les enfants très tôt
s'approprient pas par différents social
mais s'approprie l'idée de se ramener
près du monde agricole c'est déjà
découvrir des choses c'est déjà
découvrir une cuisine quand on
s'approche qui a beaucoup pénalisé la
gastronomie française c'est qu'elle
s'est coupée de saumon agricole ce qui
n'est pas le cas des Italiens par
exemple aujourd'hui manger en France pas
cher c'est quasi impossible sinon faut
aller dans des dans des chaînes voyez
c'est cette fracture qui a eu entre le
monde agricole qui aujourd'hui fait
quand même une très jolie transformation
il faut l'admettre le monde agricole est
en train de muter vers des choses
beaucoup plus saines il faut continuer à
les accompagner là-dedans mais remettre
le lien entre le monde rural et
l'univers de l'alimentation c'est il y a
cette fracture qui est qui date pour moi
je la quantifie à partir des années 70
ou vraiment même le monde paysan c'est
de son propre savoir-faire et je pense
qu'il faut ramener tout ça très par le
prisme de la scolarité mais vraiment
sous des formats
d'initiative à prendre pour pour ses
enfants qui seront les mangeurs de
demain
pour compléter on a fait une enquête
récente auprès d'étudiants pour regarder
la qualité nutritionnelle de leur
alimentation on voit bien que c'est lié
aux connaissances nutritionnelle qu'ils
ont et aussi aux compétences culinaires
qu'ils ont et on a même été jusqu'à
interroger si il possédait un épluche
légumes une passoire enfin des
instruments qui peuvent leur permettre
de cuisiner et tout ça c'est des
éléments qui contribuent à la qualité
nutritionnelle du régime donc tout ce
dont on parle connaissance et
compétences évidemment il faut le
raisonner globalement et non pas
séparément c'était ça ça contribue pour
moi à ce que devrait être l'éducation
alimentaire enfin vraiment du chant à
l'assiette et dans aussi l'art de la
dégustation mais en essayant d'éviter ce
que le risque dont parlait Jean-Pierre
dirigé en modèle ce qui ne l'est pas
forcément d'une culture à l'autre
par rapport aux étudiants qu'est-ce
qu'elles étaient les constats
que vous avez pu
alors on a vu au niveau des au niveau
des étudiants c'est on a observé trois
groupes de trois typologies de
consommateurs en fait ça c'est
particulièrement intéressant
un groupe assez majoritaire 40% de
d'étudiants qui ont une alimentation on
va dire traditionnelle plaisir de
moindre qualité nutritionnelle un groupe
frugal avec des consommations
nutritionnelles non faible enfin en
termes de quantité de calories
40% des étudiants alors ça n'était pas
lié au statut boursier parce qu'on s'est
évidemment posé cette question on a un
groupe de 20% d'étudiants pro santé
l'alimentation de très bonne qualité
nutritionnelles et en lien aussi avec
une pratique importante d'activité
physique pour prendre de la masse
musculaire c'est une tendance chez les
jeunes mais finalement qui est favorable
à une alimentation de bonne qualité
donc et dans ces différents groupes les
déterminants de la qualité
nutritionnelle de l'alimentation
s'intéresser aussi à l'impact
environnemental sont assez variables
donc justement en termes de compétences
culinaire connaissance nutritionnelle et
aussi la possibilité qu'il dispose d'un
environnement qui leur permet de
cuisiner en fait puisque c'est souvent
un problème d'avoir un accès à une
cuisine qui leur permettent d'exercer
les compétences culinaires
bon moi ce que je trouvais intéressant
c'est de voir que on avait quand même un
groupe pressenté et donc avec une
attention particulière à la santé le
groupe qui m'interroge beaucoup c'est le
groupe frugal pourquoi une alimentation
avec des apps faibles donc c'est ce
qu'on veut creuser
je peux ajouter un petit motrice bien
sûr
bien sûr
lorsque je veux dire c'est que je pense
qu'il faut ne pas oublier je pense très
bien souligner par les trois
intervenants que d'abord l'acte
alimentaire est un acte holistique c'est
à dire multidimensionnelle par essence
et que dans nos sociétés très
réductionnistes et je dirais même ultra
réductionniste puisque la pensée
complexe est un équilibre entre une
approche globale et spécifique on a
réduit l'acte alimentaire
progressivement donc il y a eu le stade
de la nutrition on s'est intéressé aux
nutriments donc on a fragmenté les
dimensions en silo ensuite on est passé
à l'ultra transformation qui est le
point ultime de cette pensée ultra
réductionniste où on fractionne
l'aliment comme un système complexe
ensuite on est passé au repas en poudre
donc on réduit l'acte alimentaire à une
poudre à reconstituer en 30 secondes
devant un écran tout seul donc c'est ça
que j'aimerais faire comprendre comment
cette pensée ultra et réductionniste
extrême à Réduit un acte de partage qui
implique de la philosophie de la
religion de l'humain à ouvre poudre à
reconstituer en 30 secondes que l'on
mange tout seul devant un écran et donc
si on ne fait rien en 2100 mangera des
gélules avec il y aura tous les
nutriments nécessaires mais je rappelle
qu'on peut remplir tous ces besoins
nutritionnels et tomber malade chronique
c'est bien démontré donc est-ce que
c'est ce qu'on veut pour 2100 donc c'est
pour ça que je porte une approche plus
holistique pour rééquilibrer les deux
approches et revenir à l'essence même de
l'alimentation qui est une discipline
quand même à l'origine madame Nicos que
je trouve la très bien souligné
multidimensionnelle et le mot clé c'est
le lien c'est comment recréer du lien à
recréer du lien entre nous quand on
partage un repas recréer du lien au sein
de l'aliment donc arrêtez de tout
fractionner de tout craquer voilà donc
le mot clé pour moi c'est recréer du
lien et retrouver du lien à tous les
niveaux de l'alimentation de l'aliment
et de la chaîne Agri agroalimentaire
Gérard long et voulait compléter
oui j'ai
j'étais très très marqué par la formule
de Jean-Pierre Poulain le reste à vivre
en réalité
le reste à vivre découle profondément
des préférences que nous que nous
manifestons dans notre attitude de
consommateur dans notre mode de vie et
l'alimentation n'est pas simplement
en quelque sorte une une fatalité
subsidiaire
c'est le résultat d'un choix que chacun
d'entre nous explicitement ou
implicitement
exprimons il y a vous avez évoqué
monsieur poulain le
panier à papa dans le budget du
particulier le numérique c'est vrai que
le numérique est un événement
considérable je ne sais pas ce qu'il
peut représenter mais c'est plusieurs
pourcentage du revenu de de chaque
ménage ou de chaque particulier et on
n'imagine pas d'ailleurs que ce
pourcentage soit décroissant même si
c'est pris ont également très
singulièrement évolué puisque l'accès
l'information l'accès à l'image l'accès
à une forme de
conviévialité qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas mais que sont les réseaux ce sont
des des prestations qui n'ont dans le
coup
cessé de diminuer
au regard des capacités que ces échanges
permettent vous avez le l'immobilier
c'est un expression d'un choix de vie je
me suis rapporteur l'objet de
l'éducation nationale et
il n'est on a les mêmes salaires dans
des régions où l'immobilier
peut varier de 1 à 10 pour en termes de
coûts pour l'utilisateur
or ce ne sont pas les régions les plus
chères qui sont nécessairement les
régions évitées c'est en général le
contraire c'est à dire pour ça qu'elles
sont chères c'est que tout le monde
envie d'y aller
et les sacrifices se traduisent
évidemment par un reste à vivre pour
reprendre ce formule qui est plus
modeste mais ça veut dire qui est même
très modeste ou un négatif
mais ça veut dire aussi que le
consommateur va le l'unité de est-ce que
c'est le ménage est-ce que c'est le
consommateur le particulier a fait d'une
certaine façon son choix alors certains
choix sont obligés prenons la résidence
il y a des villes où vous pouvez étudier
les villes où vous ne pouvez pas étudier
si vous voulez étudier et si vous voulez
enseigner il faut aller dans certaines
villes et pas d'autres et c'est plus ou
moins cher et donc le reste à vivre est
impacté donc vous adaptez c'est la
raison pour laquelle ce que je
enfin c'est pas que je regrette mais il
faut accepter l'idée
que chacun d'entre nous arbitron et
finalement parfois on préfère la
localisation le mode de loisirs
le
logement ou le numérique plutôt que la
nourriture et le
ce que l'on appelle l'ultra
transformation
aboutit à une simplicité et une
marginalisation je partage totalement
les critiques qui ont été faites sur la
diminution du goût sur
l'artificialisation sur la dépendance à
telle ou telle formule les sodas pour
les enfants
j'ai été père de famille aujourd'hui je
suis grand-père mais j'ai une
terreau d'observation extrêmement
importante il est évident que il y a des
addictions à des
à des nourritures qui sont concernantes
et qui en même temps amènent la paix
dans les familles il suffit d'être un
samedi dans une grande surface française
là où les gens sont les plus présents
pour voir que les enfants commandent
d'une certaine façon alors il commande
parce que certes la publicité la fin bon
on les achète où il est là où ça leur
fait plaisir il faut pas s'étonner
qu'ils imposent à leurs parents
des décisions dont le baron seul qui ne
sont pas très bonnes mais qui amènent la
paix dans le ménage donc tout ça est
très compliqué et je voudrais simplement
en partant de cette notion de reste à
vivre de considérer que les gens font
leur propre assez largement un arbitrage
assez conçu en beaucoup plus qu'on ne le
croit entre ce qu'ils veulent faire et
la façon dont il répartissent leurs
revenus avec ce qui serait idéal pour
dire le numérique
devrait être remplacé par la lecture
saine crayon à la main des grands
ouvrages oui c'est vrai en terme de
culture c'est mieux mais c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche dans la vraie vie et de
la même façon certes les pizzas surgelés
c'est catastrophiques mais
un dimanche soir quand toutes les
boutiques sont fermées vous n'avaient
plus rien vous la sortez vous la grillez
et vous faites non pas 3 heureux mais au
moins trois personnes qui qui
vont se satisfaire parce que tout ce qui
a été évoqué notamment par Monsieur Marx
je comprends c'est votre métier c'est
votre passion et vous avez envie de la
faire partager et je suis persuadé que
tous les Français ont envie de la
partager de temps en temps mais pas
forcément au quotidien et il faut
accepter l'idée que les produits ou les
services qui existent ne sont pas le
résultat d'un complot mais sont les
résultats d'une réponse assez simple à
des sujets qui se posent à chacun
d'entre nous et que nous arbitrons
beaucoup librement qu'on ne le croit
parce que il y a pas toujours
très intéressant votre témoignage sur
les étudiants et le fait que ceux qui
font du sport s'occupent aussi de leur
nourriture c'est très cohérent vous
occupez de votre corps vous occupez de
sa nourriture si vous occupez pas de
votre corps et si vous avez plutôt envie
de consacrer votre temps autre chose il
est vraisemblable qu'il y a toute une
série de conséquences qui vont en
découler dans votre vêtement dans votre
habillement dans votre localisation ou
dans votre nourriture et c'est cette
diversité que je voulais simplement
évoquer on a tous envie de gastronomie
pas forcément tout le temps et on a tous
envie en revanche de ne pas avoir faim
quand on a rien préparé qu'on est seul
alors c'est vrai oui le Bolino c'est pas
une perspective particulièrement
réjouissante mais il faut dans
l'arbitrage des de la complexité de la
vie les industriels de la
complémentaires ont parfaitement compris
qu'il y avait toute une série de places
alors est-ce qu'il manipule les
consommateurs
les enfants sont sans doute en effet le
public le plus
le plus facile à manipuler
les adultes moins
est-ce que l'école il peut quelque chose
je vous remercie de votre confiance dans
l'école elle a déjà beaucoup de mal
enseigné l'écriture la lecture et les
mathématiques et quant à la
l'instruction civique que vous avez
évoquée ah si seulement
j'écoute votre propos et il faut pas
confondre gastronomie et alimentation et
le poids du dérèglement de tout ça sur
la santé publique et le prix de la santé
publique en France la santé est
remboursée tant mieux et c'est un
vraiment un gage de valeur mais
aujourd'hui la santé est quand vous
voyez l'explosion de diabète de type 2
dans nos quartiers il y a quand même un
intérêt à se poser la question
non mais j'entends j'entends je veux pas
mettre tous sur le Président je veux pas
tout mettre sur le même contre mais
l'alimentation est un enjeu de santé
publique quand vous parlez de
gastronomie et de pas manger
gastronomique tous les jours je
l'entends et je l'ai évoqué j'ai dit que
la gastronomie était un épiphénomène du
monde de l'alimentation mais quand même
il faut rappeler qu'un produit doit être
bon légal et sain pour qu'il soit
commercialisable nous aujourd'hui dans
certains de nos quartiers nous avons ce
qu'on appelle les biberons noirs où on
commence à donner des sodas et là je de
3 ans
oui c'est de la réalité demandée au
dentiste ce qu'ils en pensent et
l'exposition et ça a été évoqué dans les
différentes analyses du diabète de type
2 donc il y a tout un sujet donc quand
vous dites le la l'école n'est pas
simplement le lieu où on pourrait faire
ça je vous entends là-dessus et j'ai pas
revendiqué que l'école était uniquement
le lieu à mobiliser sur l'alimentation
mais il faut quand même admettre que
l'alimentation à un poids sur la santé
publique et sur le coût de la santé
publique
bien je
vous vouliez intervenir encore je me
suis fardey
allez-y
les biberons noirs c'est trois mois
c'est pas trois ans on l'observe
beaucoup plus tôt
c'est très très inquiétant
pour bondir sur monsieur le sénateur
longueur pour le rôle de la des
industriels il y a quand même une
exploitation de l'ignorance des gens qui
est indéniable c'est-à-dire que il y a
quand même un niveau d'ignorance au
niveau alimentation qui était important
et c'est facile de l'exploiter notamment
auprès des plus défavorisés les plus
jeunes les populations à risque et il y
a des aliments quand même qui se
présentent comme des aliments sains
alors que ça n'est pas le cas c'est à
dire qu'on insiste sur un seul nutriment
et sous prétexte que l'aliment contient
ce nutriments on pense que l'ensemble
est simple mais il faut regarder
l'ensemble donc moi je pense qu'il y a
quand même de la part du marketing une
exploitation de l'ignorance des gens et
madame niclose vous parliez qu'on a créé
une demande
je sais on peut se demander par exemple
si c'est vraiment une vraie demande de
la société d'avoir des aliments pour la
transformer ça c'est une question de
fond
donc moi je pense qu'il y a quand même
une exploitation de l'ignorance des gens
juste un mot sur l'ignorance
par définition c'est la contrepartie de
l'innovation toute innovation suscite
l'ignorance de ce qui ne connaissaient
pas l'innovation et qui n'en maîtrise
pas les conséquences donc oui il y a une
ignorance oui cette ignorance est
exploitée oui il faut diminuer
l'ignorance mais vous ne supprimerez pas
l'ignorance parce que une société en
mouvement une société qui crée
par définition le créateur
invente ce que les autres ne savent pas
ou non pas fait et donc il génère de
l'ignorance par rapport à sa création
c'est tout donc je partage votre votre
avis il faut lutter contre l'ignorance
mais c'est un combat indéfini ou alors
il faut figer la connaissance et ce
n'est pas ce que nous souhaitons
oui
[Musique]
ignorance des horaires de TGV je suis
oxygène
sur la notion
sur la notion de reste à vivre moi je
viens
un territoire la plus de la moitié de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
[Musique]
avant de venir sur Paris je faisais mes
courses et à côté de moi il y avait une
dame qui faisait les siennes et
j'observais son caddie je me disais
c'est pas terrible ce qu'il y a dedans
et donc j'ai discuté avec cette dame qui
a trois enfants dans deux en bas âge et
elle m'a expliqué qu'elle avait 43 euros
l'équivalent 43 euros par semaine pour
nourrir sa famille donc deux adultes
trois enfants dont deux en bas âge
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire avec ça
le reste à vivre là il sait pas un choix
elle a pas choisi d'avoir 43 euros pour
fond pour nourrir sa famille
elle n'a pas d'abonnement internet elle
n'a pas de station de jeu
elle vit entre quatre tôles parce que
c'est voilà
et pour cette dame et pour beaucoup de
foyers en Polynésie dans je pense que
c'est une généralité dans les outre-mer
au moins pour les enfants scolarisés
peut-être moins pour les étudiants le
seul repas équilibré qu'ils vont faire
de la journée c'est celui qu'ils vont
prendre à l'école
donc pour moi le rôle de l'école c'est
c'est ce serait effectivement formidable
qu'on puisse qu'on puisse faire des
cours de cuisine et je suis d'accord
avec cette approche de l'école de la vie
c'est cette école des choses où on peut
faire à la fois des maths enfin tout un
ensemble en faisant un cours de cuisine
mais le rôle de l'école il est aussi je
pense au travers des cantines scolaires
de s'assurer qu'au moins ce repas là il
est fait dans de bonnes conditions
nutritionnelles et par rapport au sujet
de notre audition d'aujourd'hui qu'on
s'assure que il soit le plus exemple
possible de produits qui puisse être
néfaste
dans la loi climat et résilience j'avais
posé un amendement pour
réduire le recours au plat ultra
transformé dans les cantines il m'avait
été répondu à l'époque qu'on ne savait
pas ce qui était un plat ultra il y
avait pas de définition de plat ultra
transformé donc ça a été rejeté voilà
donc je pense qu'on a encore à
travailler sur ce sujet et au vu de ce
qu'on a entendu ce matin et je remercie
beaucoup tous les intervenants nous
allons encore creuser et permettre de
voilà qu'on mette en place des des
garde-fous quelque part sur ces sujets
là parce que moi je suis persuadée aussi
que on a certes il y a l'innovation on
met sur le marché différentes choses
mais les consommateurs doivent
à minima vu les conséquences sur la
santé connaître un petit peu mieux ces
sujets là le savoir et que ce soit pas
juste des petites choses
inscrites toutes petites sur les sur les
plats sur les emballages donc voilà
c'est on a du travail à faire sur nous
parlementaire sur ce sujet pour essayer
de faire en sorte de limiter et de
protéger les populations qui vont
recourir à ces achats sans trop savoir à
quoi elle s'expose en fait c'est pour
moi c'est un sujet voilà merci
bien écoutez nous allons pouvoir
conclure ces deux tables rondes à mon
tour je voudrais remercier l'ensemble
des participants cela va permettre de
pouvoir compléter et proposer donc lors
d'une prochaine audition une note sur
l'impact de l'alimentation
ultra transformé par notre collègue je
remercie également pour son implication
importante ici mais évidemment lors des
différents projets de loi sur lesquels
nous pouvons
évoquer le sujet de l'alimentation ultra
transformée nous aurons l'occasion
également aussi de faire des je l'espère
des recommandations en ce sens qui
pourront pouvoir qui pourront servir
notamment lors de débats parlementaire
et évidemment sur lesquels nous nous
prendrons nous prendrons bien en compte
les différents éléments scientifiques
les questions également
d'ordre
éthique d'ordre également presque
parfois
sociétaux on l'a vu c'est le sujet est
vraiment lié pour l'ensemble de nos
collègues parlementaires merci à tous et
donc nous allons pouvoir lever la séance
merci merci beaucoup au revoir merci au
revoir au revoir au revoir